Das war's für heute.
Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute. Bis zum nächsten Mal.
Das war's für heute.
Easy, easy, easy, easy.
So Leute, ich bin am Start, ich hab irgendwie mein Headset verknotet, was ist hier los?
Ah, auf geht's!
Was meint ihr? Also es ist noch keiner da, bringt nichts wenn ich frage, ne?
Mal hier refreshen, ob überhaupt jemand schon am Start ist.
Drei Leute sind am Start, das bin ich, zweimal vom Refreshen des Chats.
Aber jetzt kommen sie so langsam mit der Zeit.
Zorix ist am Start, exellent.
Jetzt kommen sie langsam hier.
Also Leute, ich habe die letzten Tage relativ viel Modern Warfare gespielt.
Ich weiß auch nicht was mit mir los ist, warum ich jetzt auf einmal anfange das Spiel zu spielen.
Ich finde den Multiplay immer noch ziemlich kacke.
Aber Warzone und Tour and Tour macht Bock.
Ich glaube ich habe die letzten paar Tage irgendwie 20 Stunden oder so.
Ja, jetzt kommen sie alle hier.
Der Alex ist am Start, Tribulon ist da, Vegas ist da, der Umut ist da, Lukitsu ist da, das Zocker Imperium ist am Start.
X-Hack-Y-X, exellent Name.
Akina ist 99, Mark Yolo, Power Planter, der Name kommt mir irgendwie bekannt von Power Planter.
Suni ist da, Q-Sword ist da, der Tebe ist da, jetzt kommen sie hier, jetzt geht es los.
Ich habe mir gedacht, ich muss unbedingt den Windows XP Hintergrund machen, weil mir der Windows 10 Hintergrund so auf den Kicks geht.
Und da ist mir aufgefallen, dass wenn man den Hintergrund ändert, dass das Menü im Vergleich zu den meisten anderen Windows 10 Menüs tatsächlich funktioniert.
Die meisten Windows 10 Menüs ansonsten haben entweder Optionen oder man weiß nicht wo man was findet.
Aber das Menü hat funktioniert, ich meine es ist ein bisschen unsinnig quasi ein extra Setting dafür zu machen, da ist im Prinzip nichts da.
Sag mal, konnte man nicht mal die Farben, doch die Farben konnte man doch auch mal ändern.
Hier die Farben, man konnte doch mal die Farben von der Taskleiste ändern, oder?
Das ging doch, ja.
Übrigens auch eine Sache, die mir bei den Windows 10 Settings mega auf den Sack geht, ist, dass man nur ein Settings Menü richtig öffnen kann.
Guck, wenn ich jetzt die Taskbar Settings aufmachen will und mache jetzt die Background Settings, dann sind das keine zwei Fenster, sondern nur eins, das ist totaler Müll.
Wie konnte man die Farbe von der Taskbar ändern, weil die passt überhaupt nicht dazu.
Ne, oh das sieht jetzt fast wieder aus wie Windows XP.
Unter Colors?
Ne, ne, kann man nicht.
Das wäre zu einfach, wenn das unter Colors funktionieren würde.
Locked Taskbar, all high.
Das, das, das hat...
Ne, das war was anderes.
Das da? Ne, das ist nicht Taskbar.
Das ist für alles.
Das ist komplette Colors, ich will ja nur die Taskbar ändern.
Das ist Colors für alles.
Guck, das ist für Fenster und für Taskbar.
Ich will nur die Taskbar ändern, das scheint zu viel zu sein für Windows.
Guck, das hier ändert alles.
Ich sehe überhaupt keinen Unterschied ehrlich gesagt.
Ich sehe keinen Unterschied.
Kann man doch nicht mehr, echt nicht?
Ach, Windows, egal, scheiß drauf.
Wir haben den Windows XP Hintergrund, jetzt ist alles gut.
Excellent.
Was machst du denn Samstag? Sonntag ist es ja, was machst du denn auf der Arbeit?
Ach ja.
Zocker Imperium, schieß los, was denn?
Ja, das kann man nur alles ändern und nicht einzeln, okay?
Willst du meinen Desktop nicht... Ne, den Desktop mache ich ja extra so,
dass der Chat sich jedes Mal freuen kann, wenn man meinen Desktop sieht.
Die Telekontrollpost kann man mal löschen.
Oh, das sortiert gar nicht mehr automatisch.
Excellent.
Shortcut Clap.
Ah ja, den brauchen wir natürlich unbedingt.
Video MP4 brauchen wir auch nicht mehr.
Ubuntu ISO brauchen wir auch nicht.
Ubuntu.
Haben wir eigentlich schon mal versucht,
ob das koreanische Text zu Speech Ubuntu aussprechen kann?
Ich hoffe, es kackt jetzt nicht ab.
Ubuntu.
Kannst du das?
Oh, ich hab's gecrashed, Leute.
Ich hab's gecrashed, RIP.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen kaputt.
Manchmal crashts bei der Text-zu-Speech-Auswahl.
Der Bock ist.
Ubuntu.
Okay, es crasht gerade die ganze Zeit.
Warum crasht das die ganze Zeit? Das ist aber schlecht.
Da kann ich ja nix mehr hinzufügen.
So vielleicht an und aus machen und jetzt Ubuntu reinschreiben.
Ah, jetzt gehts.
Erstmal im Stream fixen.
Das hört sich aber kacke an.
Das hört sich ja übelst...
Das hört sich übelst bescheid an.
Ubuntu.
Was man ja gar nicht so ausspricht, aber gut.
Leute, es geht doch fast.
Ubuntu.
Fast, fast.
Das geht doch sogar.
Das ist doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Ubuntu.
Oh man.
So, ich muss erstmal ein bisschen kleiner machen hier das...
Oh.
Ich kann das Fenster nicht anklicken.
Oh, mega lull.
Jetzt.
Perfekt.
Sehr schön.
So, jetzt haben wir jetzt erstmal ein bisschen sinnloses Zeug rumgeklickt.
Perfekt.
So, also, was war mit...
Oh, ich muss mal mein Frage-Border noch anschmeißen, sehe ich gerade.
Als Go-Application.
Oh.
Poggers.
Warum dann ausgerechnet in Go?
Was?
Okay, Windows, was ist los?
Ah, excellent.
Das ist das sinnloseste Menü in ganz Windows.
Verwendet das wirklich irgendjemand?
Einmal piss dich, Alter.
Okay, okay.
Einmal.
Piss dich, Alter.
Piss dich also.
Irgendjemand wollte was über OBS wissen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich es übersehen habe oder ob da nichts mehr gekommen ist.
So.
Pepega-Board läuft.
Alles gut.
Oh, doch nicht.
Ja, läuft.
Sehr gut.
Excellent.
Wir lösen mal die alten Fragen.
Oh, bam.
Jetzt sind wir wieder.
Jetzt sind wir wieder clear.
Okay.
Oh, nee.
Das Video, das ist...
Ich sehe den Titel schon.
Das Video hat Trigger-Potenzial.
Okay.
Das wird uns gleich schwanken.
Mal gucken, wie gut das gemacht ist.
Okay.
Hallo?
Ich will das anklicken.
Lass den Ofen-Hack schauen.
Wo ist denn der Ofen-Hack?
Wo ist der Ofen-Hack?
This video is brought to you by...
Squarespace.
Zocker Imperium schreibt, ich habe neulich Warsong gezockt und nach der ersten Runde
hatte ich ein Sound-Delay von etwa einer Sekunde.
Das passiert jedes Mal und ich habe keine Ahnung weshalb.
Das hatte ich auch mal.
Was man umstellen kann ist oder was man mal ausprobieren kann ist, ich glaube hier...
Properties?
Ja, du kannst mal hier Timestamps an- und ausschalten und gucken, ob es damit irgendwie
geht.
Du kannst mal ausschalten.
Das Problem hatte ich auch mal und ich habe dann Timestamps, glaube ich, ausgeschaltet.
Soll das echt sein, Ed Wobblos?
Weiß nicht.
Mal gucken.
Was, was ist das denn?
Der hat auf jeden Fall schon mal die richtige Videolänge, muss man ja sagen, ne?
Ok, was?
The most dangerous comment on YouTube, everyone's account is at risk.
Ok.
Das können wir gleich mal ausprobieren.
Wir laden uns einfach den Bot runter und dann übernehmen wir 30 Milliarden YouTube-Accounts.
Easy.
Easy as f**k.
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal an.
There's more than one chaotic...
Das gucken wir uns gleich mal an, bin ich mal gespannt.
Ähm, was hast du, der Matze fragt, hast du mal mit Cisco gearbeitet?
Ja, ich hab, ich hab, also Basics, oder Basics darf man ja heute nicht mal sagen, man muss
ja heute sagen, die, was, wie ging das, wie ging das noch mal, Chat, die Basics muss man
doch sagen, oder?
Basics ist ja out.
Das heißt, das ist dann auch nicht mehr der YouTube-Channel HowToBasic, HowToBasics,
sondern HowToBasics.
Hast du schon mal Frag1Millionär schon gesehen auf YouTube?
Ich glaube schon, ja.
Aus der Bound F-Rest, ich hab die, ich hab einen riesen Bogen um die ganzen Videos gemacht,
ey.
Ähm, hast du, also hast du mal mit Cisco gearbeitet, ich hab mir mal überlegt, Mikrotik-Switches
zu kaufen, findet die Konfiguration aber etwas unübersichtlich, kannst du mal zeigen, wie
man VLANs einrichtet?
Ja, die Mikrotik-Konfiguration ist tatsächlich ein bisschen unübersichtlich, ähm, wenn
man sich mal an die Cisco-Commando-Zeilen Sachen gewöhnt hat, dann ist das deutlich
einfacher als das Mikrotik-Zeug.
Es gibt unter, für Mikrotik gibt es, ich kann jetzt mal kurz zeigen, so ganz grob, wenn
ich das überhaupt zusammenkrieg jetzt, ähm, okay, also, ähm, es gibt zwei Wege, wie man,
wie man unter Mikrotik VLANs konfiguriert, es gibt den alten Weg und den neuen Weg, die
empfehlen natürlich nur noch den neuen Weg zu verwenden, ich glaube das ist mein, oder
ist es gerade kaputt?
Ich glaub die, ich glaub die, äh, RouterOS Demo geht nicht, ist kaputt.
Oh, da war's, da war's, fuck, ich war zu schnell, bonkers, das ist einfach nur langsam,
oh fuck, es ist einfach nur, was ist das denn, ah, jetzt geht's, okay, ähm, das RouterOS,
genau, also ich, das ist echt ekelig, also es gibt, warte mal, ähm, wo war denn da,
wo war der Kampf-Verstell, es gibt zwei Wege, man kann einmal ne neue Bridge anlegen und
die kann man VLAN taggen, das ist der alte Weg, genau, ähm, darf man hier überhaupt
irgendwas, irgendwas auswählen, das ist der alte Weg, so, und dann gab es den neuen Weg,
genau, da liegt, ah fuck, Interface, ah, ich kann überhaupt nichts machen hier drinnen,
okay, wunderbar, excellent, ich hab gar keine Interfaces, ja, sehr schön, äh, oder muss
ich einen neuen Interface anlegen, äh, das ist jetzt natürlich ein bisschen, äh, ein
bisschen merkwürdig, wenn man, äh, RouterOS ohne Interfaces hat, okay, zumindest man muss
dann irgendwo hier, muss man, äh, muss man WLAN Interfaces anlegen und dann ist das irgendwie
total versteckt gewesen und dann muss man irgendwie festlegen, welche VLANs auf welchem
Interface erlaubt sind, das ist, die Konfiguration ist ein bisschen durch die Brust ins Auge,
ich hab das damals nach diesem Guide gemacht, ähm, ich hab das nach diesem Guide, ja, ich
glaub nach dem hier, ja, nach diesem Guide hab ich das damals, äh, mir angeguckt, wie
das funktioniert, das ist die neue, das ist der neue Weg, wie man die Sachen konfiguriert,
das heißt, das ist richtig, so wie er es hier schreibt, viele Sachen kann man weglassen,
ja, also man muss da nicht zwangsläufig irgendwelche Routen und sonst was setzen, wenn man das
nicht, genau das hier meine ich, das ist das, was ein bisschen kompliziert ist, du musst
dann irgendwie in die Pledge-Settings reingehen und da stehen dann die ganzen, unter Ports
stehen die einzelnen VLANs und da musst du irgendwie einstellen, okay, auf welchem Port
erlaub ich welches VLAN und was ist die Fault, sprich, ist es die Fault untagged, wo kommt
es rein, es ist echt nicht einfach, das ist ein bisschen kompliziert, also man muss sagen,
das machen sie bei Cisco schon besser, beziehungsweise es macht so ziemlich jeder x-beliebige Managed
Switch besser, da geht man nämlich einfach in das Interface rein und stellt eine VLAN
ID ein und drückt auf okay und es ist fertig, warum die das so kompliziert gemacht haben
unter RouterOS, verstehe ich auch nicht, also du musst dir mal die Anleitung hier angucken,
nach der habe ich, äh, nein, die Anleitung hier, nach der habe ich mir das damals auch
angeguckt, wie es funktioniert, es ist ein bisschen eklig, das stimmt, so, jetzt gucken
wir uns mal das Video an, das angeblich alle YouTube Accounts at risk sind, also ich monke
es, bisschen leiser, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, ja,
ja, ja, ja, ja, ja, das
Almost instantly when they upload and somehow if you click that seems to not they're getting
your information and spoofing YouTube Accounts, then using those YouTube Accounts to fake interaction
on their own videos.
gesehen wannabe friends
mal gucken mal gucken was da dran ist
and now it appears they've been able to actually hack and take full-on YouTube
accounts this is a major major security breach das kann ich mir gar nicht
vorstellen aber mal gucken
gut ich habe in discord ich habe in discord zum glück keine keine telefonnummer
das was hinterlegt they seem to be gathering data on people through a discord which i'll talk about uh which is how i suspect that they are getting access to everybody's accounts this is a major major security breach team youtube please dm me quickly the the person that even exposed this had their account hacked and taken away from them in mere hours and legitimately i'm concerned about uploading this myself so if my account gets gets gets weird don't don't unsubscribe just know
that i probably got hacked for expo ja jetzt aber jetzt ist das ist ja nicht das jetzt hier auf einmal aus aus dem blauen hinaus alle accounts gehackt werden
reach out and please i know it's gonna be long but it's a lot of information and get it out there you know what forget it i just talked to the the guy that actually exposed this and we agreed that i'm just it's better to just use his video on the end of mine i'm gonna leave a link to the original section down below please stop by evans 111 channel terrible name but once you get your channel back we'll make you know i'll make fun of you for
that but uh again this is a full on mobilization request leave a like on the video comment on the video and i'll leave a link to the tweet uh and and uh generally if everyone rushes that and likes it retweets it team youtube will get back to us the same day i don't know if it's a spoof or a hack but if it's a hack it's potentially tens of thousands of accounts if it's a spoof it's it's just as bad people leaving comments there's clearly
something crazy access that these people have to videos behind it looks like uh privated settings they can see videos behind private i don't know youtube this needs to happen but i'm going to just cut to evans video because it's just way better than anything i could do on it so watch it please mobilize and be very careful if you see this comment around or this youtuber
if you want to gather information look at something else what do you have anything suspicious email me at the quartering at gmail.com because so far he only told three minutes so ultra dangerous and very bad and you really learned something
there's more than one chaotic force of nature festering its way across the world right now the difference is what i'm going to be talking about today is not only far more contagious but you're not even safe from it inside your own home the worst part is all you need to do to get affected by this phenomenon is to answer one simple question want to be friends if you follow any smaller creators you'll have almost definitely seen this line of text in their comment section i can without a doubt say it's the widest spread
comment i've ever seen but it's so much more malicious than it seems on the surface man kann jetzt man könnte die leute wahrscheinlich voll trollen indem man jetzt einfach bei ihnen unter die comments pauses want to be friends first i thought it was an upstart youtube channel trying to do some marketing but it quickly dawned on me how much more sinister this situation was thousands of people have lost their entire channels from this one innocent comment and it's one of the largest security breaches i've seen youtube go through throughout my decade on the platform
stay until the end of the video and you'll find out not only how dangerous this simple comment is and how to stay safe from it but also how it's led to one of the fastest growing channels on the platform
since logan paul speaking of logan that happens to be one of the many aliases this comment has been posted by and it's also the one i've personally been plagued by it would appear it's the first two comments on every new video of mine sometimes before they'd even gone public so something was already suspicious i did some investigating by asking on both my twitter and subreddit the response was instantaneous which confirmed my theory the scale of this comment was unprecedented i'd seen it on videos
besides mine and i wasn't the only one to put it in perspective if you search any words into the youtube search bar and filter results by upload time you're bound to find this comment on whatever you click on no matter what it's about no matter how many views that video currently has so it's just a process that someone is using to advertise their channel right well advertising is a bit of a stretch the truth is unfortunately far less innocent than that when i started investigating this i didn't really realize how much
a can of worms it was so i didn't know where to ask i started on twitter and got a few positive responses from people i knew and then i made a post on the out of the loop subreddit in case it was a trend that youtube had started
or it was some kind of meme or something that i wasn't aware of i did actually get a fair bit of information out of the out of the loop subreddit but unfortunately people didn't answer in the proper form
but i did get some information out of the subreddit
but for some people right now it's a reality please if you see this account in the comments of any video
so gucken wir uns mal lesen wir uns mal an was die experten dazu sagen nämlich auf reddit feels reddit man
was
ja könnte ich mir auch vorstellen das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen
das könnte ich mir auch vorstellen
hast du den twitch emotepark gestern mitbekommen nee was war da
der titel alter der titel ich glaube das ist das ist irgendein fake kram
ich glaube das ist irgendein fake kram
keine ahnung ich glaube das ist ziemlicher blödsinn
ja vor allem würde sowas nicht mehrere tage lang gehen wenn das youtube was nightbot war kaputt
nightbot should be back online on twitch and this time it looks there was unhandled emote data
ah ok unser nightbot funktioniert noch oder funktioniert der nightbot noch
ja geht noch alles gut unser nightbot ist nicht betroffen alles klar was hat eben einer für ein
video gepaustet irgendeiner ist sauer auf linux ich soll mir das mal angucken
auf tracks tracks linux nummer 11 oder bin ich ja mal gespannt linux ist total der track ok
das fängt gut an das fängt gut an bin ich mal gespannt das fängt schon mal exzellent an
seid ihr auch solche leute die bock auf dem betriebssystem haben auf dem keine programme
laufen dann seid ihr bei linux genau richtig vielleicht hat ja der eine oder andere von
dem betriebssystem schon mal gehört linux ist ein krebsgeschwür artiges betriebssystem
dass sich manche leute tatsächlich freiwillig installieren das ist ein troll video oder und
manche sagen war hey ist es sogar die bessere alternative zu windows bevor sie sich dann ist
es nicht linux ersetzt kein winn los installieren weil es dann doch nicht so geil war wie sie dachten
nun und heute möchte ich mal darüber reden warum das betriebssystem eigentlich so scheiße ist ich
habe schon wirklich so viele linux fanboys kennengelernt die meinten immer ja linux ist
besser weil es ist open source und kosten was weiß ich ich meine kostenlos ist ja schön und gut ich
kann auch an atomreaktor vorbeilaufen wir kostenlos krebs holen das ist kein argument wir leben im
fucking jahr 2018 wo man fast fast windows schon recht günstig kaufen kann also ein paar euro
den preis geht es echt nicht das stimmt da hat da hat er vollkommen also den preis geht es wirklich
nicht also der punkt fällt schon mal flach kommen wir mal vielleicht in den punkt bedienung seit
windows xp ist ja die bedienung auch für anfänger sehr sehr angenehm gestaltet windows wister war
ein bisschen fragwürdig aber naja windows 7 war eigentlich wieder ganz gut windows 8 war ein sehr
kacheles projekt und minus 10 finde ich persönlich gut ja kommen wir mal zu linux linux hat sich
über die jahre auch eine recht nette grafische oberfläche aufgebaut tja während da nicht immer
noch diese konsolenbefehle naja gut das ist das ist halt so die sache das ist auch das was ich
immer sage wenn die leute sagen alter ich habe keinen bock mehr auf windows ich wechsle jetzt
auf linux da sage ich ihnen auch immer stell dich mal drauf ein dass das nicht einfach installiert
wird und eins zu eins ersatz ist das ist was komplett anderes und für leute die sich damit
auseinandersetzen ist das hier eine super geschichte für leute die einfach nur den windows ersatz
suchen ist das nix funktionen die man windows einfach über die grafische oberfläche kontrollieren
das sage ich ja immer das stimmt es manchmal in linux einfach nichts wenn ihr unter linux versucht
das wlan einzurichten wird die sache ein bisschen haarig ich meine das kommt das kommt drauf an ob
es einfach so funktioniert also das ist das ist einer der großen unterschiede finde ich
zwischen windows und linux unter linux hast du viele sachen die gehen instant aber wenn sie
nicht gehen ist ist es entweder gar nicht möglich oder nur übelst rum gehacke am start so das
hast du unter windows ein bisschen anders unter windows gehen viele sachen nicht direkt aber lassen
sich relativ einfach beheben ja und seit es deshalb für jede noch so exotische hardware
irgendwas offizielles vom hersteller gibt es doch mal an wer will die kacke da eintippen und das
ist immer noch das ganze problem an linux man muss noch viel über die konsole machen ich gebe
zu es ist nützlich man weiß wie man damit umgeht auch unter windows aber wir haben immer noch das
jahr 2018 wo ist denn die benutzerfreundlichkeit die konsole ist je nachdem was man machen muss
deutlich benutzerfreundlicher als eine grafische oberfläche allerdings nicht für den 0815 user
der einen windows ersatz sucht ich will genauso alles über die grafische oberfläche steuern
können wie auch beim terminal und genau das ist das fucking problem an linux das benutzen hauptsächlich
nur leute die halt cool wirken wollen mit den ganzen scheiß getippen die terminal konsole
guck mal ich mache nichts mit der grafische oberfläche sondern nur alles ins terminal weil
ich einfach so cool bin und gegen die mainstream bin genauso ist das linux ist
einfach teilweise das ist doch der ist es nicht der germany's next top model typ
das ist der wahrheit linux ist einfach teilweise eine mode erscheinung weil leute sich selbst
von anderen abheben wollen und einfach cool wirken wollen sowas wie hipster oder sowas
wie leute die extra sich vegan ernähren und was da genau tut mir leid ist so ja ja und das andere
große problem es gibt einfach keine anwendung das ist wenn man sich diese anwendung angucken
war ja das stimmt also die 0815 mainstream sachen gibt es da nicht deswegen sage ich auch es ist
kein guter ersatz wenn man einfach windows kann wenn man kein buck mal windows hat und
einfach wenn das runterschmeißen will und sagen mit linux ist so viel besser ganz vergessen du
wirst dafür kein sony vegas kriegen wobei es ja mittlerweile zumindest was video editing angeht
wohl angeblich ich habe nichts davon ausprobiert muss ich ehrlich sagen ganz gute sachen gibt
grafisch gibt es da nichts vergleichbares zu sag mal irgendwie einem affinity designer oder
photoshop oder sonst was jetzt kommt keiner mit gimp an dafür gibt es unter linux viele andere
sachen die du so unter windows nicht zum laufen kriegst versuch mal einen netzwerk test zu machen
unter windows riesenakt iperf ist bis heute verbugt unter windows und es gibt jede menge sachen es ist
halt unterschiedliche einsatzzwecke deswegen mache ich ja bei mir auch so hier auf dem desktop ganz
einfach ich verwende für alles wo man windows gut verwenden kann also für mein video zeug für
streaming zeug für spiele verwende ich windows so und für alles andere wenn ich 30 million mark
kappa drinnen nur weil das bord ist ein bisschen verbugt aber für alles andere wo ich irgendwas
programmieren muss oder wo ich irgendwas netzwerk mäßig machen muss man sonst nämlich linux das
ist ja gerade das ist ja gerade das schöne daran dass man nicht das eine oder das andere verwenden
muss sondern man kann einfach das nehmen und das ist das was bei vielen fanboy diskussionen immer
außen vor bleibt es macht überhaupt keinen sinn zu sagen das ist das beste für alles und das ist
das beste für jenes oder so man muss einfach gucken ist wie bei programmiersprachen so was
nehme ich jetzt dafür dass man einfach guckt was ist jetzt was gut passt für das was ich machen
will und da nimmt man das einfach und wenn jetzt einer sagt hey ich nehme noch zusätzlich den
mac weil dort die integration mit mit kalender und to do's und und terminen und was auch immer noch
alles mir besser gefällt das soll halt noch meck dazu nehmen warum nicht und spätestens wenn man
mal an bereich geht wenn es um serverprogramme geht oder irgendwelche automatisierung scripting
sonst was geschichten da ist linux schlicht und ergreifend windows meilenweit voraus das kann mir
keiner erzählen dass windows settings in irgendeiner art und weise intuitiv zu bedienen werden mit
drei menüs und unter menüs wo man dann irgendwann in den winners 311 fenster teilweise rauskommt
wenn man hier sagen will zum beispiel selbst mein lieblingsbeispiel dafür wenn man jetzt die
settings von meinem mikrofon zum beispiel einstellen will oder von meinem audio ausgang da muss ich
hier erstmal auf open sound settings so dann passiert manchmal nix open sound settings neues
menü sound control panel windows xp menü dann gehst du hier rein da kriegste windows 2000 menü
und dann gehst du in support formats rein so und das kannst du halt nicht gescheit woanders einstellen
das ist nicht intuitiv ja mac os kann man als vm machen doch geht ich weiß aber nicht ob ich
das on stream zeigen darf weil ich glaube apple mag das nicht und vmware braucht auch einen patch
den man entweder sich runterladen kann oder mit dem hex editor an zwei stellen was eintragen muss
das dann geht es auch man kann also ich habe das schon ausprobiert man kann mac os unter vm
wer laufen lassen das funktioniert am besten ist wenn man sich so ein fertig fertiges image
runter lädt wo auch schon das bootloader zeug und so alles alles gepatcht ist das funktioniert
eigentlich ganz gut das problem ist dass es halt keine grafische beschleunigung gibt und mac os
ohne 3d beziehungsweise halt ohne ohne grafikkarte für beschleunigung ist nicht richtig benutzbar
und 3d acceleration über vmware geht nicht mit mac os also man kann mac os virtualisieren aber
es funktioniert nicht richtig also es funktioniert schon aber es ist es ist nicht schön flüssig zu
bedienen das einzige was vielleicht spektakulär ist dass man sich mein zubehör runterladen kann
nach fünf minuten habe es durchgezockt und dann denkt man nein das stimmt nicht das wichtigste
spiel unter linux ist immer noch super tux card ja leute super super tux card das allerwichtigste
spiel was man nur haben kann wenn man wenn man linux linux hat super tux card das allerwichtigste
excellent super tux card beste ich weiß wie geht man gas super tux card beste und mittlerweile
sieht super tux card sogar guckt euch das mal außerhalb an von von der strecke es sieht sogar
mittlerweile ganz ok aus ja mario kart für arme ja es ist super tux card aber es sieht aber es
sieht ich mein man darf nicht vergessen es läuft in der vm ja es läuft in der vm und das sieht
mittlerweile das spiel gibt es ja auch schon 30 jahre oder so gefühlt und das sieht mittlerweile
ganz ok aus heißt fühlt sich schon ein bisschen fail an an manchen stellen aber es ist an sich
vollkommen in ordnung ja super tux card das aller das allerwichtigste spiel was man überhaupt
braucht unter linux super tux also nix von wegen mein sweeper super tux card nach fünf minuten
haben wir es durchgezockt und dann denkt man sich mann scheiße warum habe ich linux installiert
wäre ich lieber bei windows geblieben da gab es noch wesens geiles team games ja ich weiß
mittlerweile kam ja auch steamspiel läuft läuft aber so gut wie nix aber derzeit sieht steam für
linux auch nicht mehr so rosig aus auf windows da hat sich das ok das ist im jahr 2020 nicht
immer ganz aktuell es gibt zwar relativ wenig spiele unter linux in steam native wenn man
sich das anguckt im vergleich zu windows es gibt viel mehr als früher das muss man auch
sagen also da hat sich schon einige hat sich richtig viel getan die letzten jahre auch die
letzten zwei jahre also die steam bibliothek sieht bei weitem nicht mehr so leer aus wie noch vor
nach einer weile das ist schon besser durch diese ganze geschichte dass sie jetzt ein proton und
wie heißt das andere zeug supporten ist es viel einfacher wenn aus spiele mittlerweile unter
linux zum laufen zu bringen wie früher allerdings ist das nach wie vor immer noch eine ziemliche
krücke und spätestens bei multiplayer spielen mit anti cheat ist vorbei also es gibt eigentlich
keinen sinn zu sagen ich windows fack mich ab aber ich spiele hauptsächlich und ich benutze
jetzt linux weil da läuft alles drauf du kriegst du kriegst relativ schnell probleme und wie gesagt
und spätestens wenn du multiplayer sachen mit anti cheat spielst es eh vorbei also ist linux
in der hinsicht auch kein argument und auch wenn alle sagen es ist so viel sicherer es gibt keine
viren und so dann denkt mal nach warum weil einfach keiner bock hat diesen scheiß zu nutzen aber
denken sich den scheiß benutzt doch eh keiner warum sollten wir da vieren schreiben da ist was
dran da ist was dran allerdings kann man auch sagen dass die rechte verwaltung und wie das
standardmäßig gehandelt wird mit admin rechten unter linux zumindest wenn man es mit den älteren
windows versionen vergleicht deutlich besser gewesen ist das gab es so unter windows ja eine
ganze zeit nicht mittlerweile hast ja dass dass du wenn du admin werden musst auch erst mal passport
eintipp also das ja quasi das grafische sudo mittlerweile unter windows auch aber ansonsten
sind vieren unter linux natürlich rein user space mäßig auch möglich und linux hat auch genug
fehler um gut rechte zu erlangen die man ab muss man sich nur mal verfolgen allerdings sind die
meistens relativ schnell weg und es ist jetzt ja nicht so dass es da täglich was neues gibt also
ich würde schon sagen dass wenn aus prinzipiell eine ganze ecke sicherer ist als als windows
natürlich trägt er die verbreitung auch dazu bei natürlich das trägt ganz klar trägt trägt auch
dazu bei dass es nicht so verbreitet ist und das windows softer standardmäßig nicht unter linux
läuft sollte mal der unwahrscheinliche fall kommt dass wirklich viele viele leute haben ich
gesagt wenn das ist sicher als wenn das excellent ja ist ja auch so wenn aus zehn ist bestimmt
sicher als wenn aus 98 da wobei wenn ich mir gar nicht so sicher für wenn aus 98 gibt es
wahrscheinlich nichts mehr ja aber pauschal würde ich schon sagen dass du unter linux eine ganze
ecke sicherer unterwegs bist als unter windows wie gesagt vor allem was auch gerade einer im chat
geschrieben hat die meisten sachen laufen halt komplett ins leere sei es jetzt irgendwelche mail
anhänge oder irgendwelche drive bei geschichten im browser das meiste funktioniert unter linux
halt nicht ja klar natürlich unter anderem auch weil keiner auf linux irgendwie wert legt aber
unterm strich bist du trotzdem sicher unterwegs das ist halt total bescheuert zu sagen es ist
jetzt negativ für für linux in irgendeiner art und weise dann würde es auch logischerweise mehr
viren für dieses system geben die programmiert werden und wir sehen halt auch mal davon ab dass
es auch viele hardware beziehungsweise treibe probleme gibt wenn man linux auf dem system
installiert ja ja was für ein argument bleibt denn jetzt für linux im privatbereich den übrig
also da gibt es gibt es einige zum beispiel wenn man den server betreiben will dann ist das
deutlich einfacher wenn man sachen programmieren will wenn man sachen automatisieren will wenn
man sich ein bisschen für technik interessiert und gucken wir wie manche sachen funktionieren
es gibt sehr viele es gibt massiggründe sich privat mit mit linux zu beschäftigen vor allem
wenn man mal anguckt wie viel software es in so einem paket manager drin gibt der unterschied
windows zu aktualisieren versus linux programe zu aktualisieren ist immer noch 20 jahre später
ein himmel weiter unterscheiden einfach paket manager update machen oder erst mal 30 minos
programe abdehnen es gibt viele sachen die dafür sprechen linux zu verwenden aber wie gesagt
halt nicht für den 0815 windows benutzer der sagt oder wenn aus zehn geht mir auf den sack ich
benutze jetzt linux dafür ist es nix mir fällt jetzt kein privacy zum beispiel es gibt zig gründe
ja habe ich ja auch gerade schon gesagt aber ja privacy ist tatsächlich auch ein großer grund aber
mir geht es vor allem da also warum ich linux verwende ist einfach weil ich mich erstens für
technik sachen interessiert zweitens weil es deutlich einfacher ist irgendwelche sachen zu
programmieren es sei denn es ist jetzt dort net und windows desktop geschichten unter windows sobald
du irgendwelche netzwerks sachen machen willst ist das unter linux viel viel einfacher und der
windows musste erstmal ich weiß gar nicht gibt es gibt es überhaupt einen engine x oder irgendwas
für windows keine ahnung habe ich nicht ausprobiert es hat seinen grund dass 80 prozent oder 90 prozent
des internets mittlerweile unter unter linux läuft und für mich was er jetzt eben als als recht
negativ dargestellt hat für jemand der der kein 0815 ich klicke in der grafischen oberfläche noob
ist und ein bisschen andere ansprüche hat für mich ist das eine tolle geschichte dass es eine
kommando zeile gibt weil allein schon das terminal und die kommando zeile an sich unter linux da
gibt es standardmäßig nichts aber wirklich gar nichts was unter windows mithalten kann ich
meine es wird jetzt habe ich sogar das falsche gestartet also wenn man sich das standard
winsterminal anguckt dann mal das mit einem terminal vergleicht ist halt der witz und
selbst das was die standardmäßig als befehle drin ist ist komplett komplett für den arsch
ja es gibt power shell allerdings power shell ist eher gut für automatisierungen als für als für
eine interaktive shell also ich komme mit power shell ich habe es ein bisschen probiert mal ich
komme mit power shell als interaktive shell überhaupt nicht klar für irgendwelche skripte und
windows automatisierung sachen oder sei es jetzt für irgendwelche admins die beim logon sachen
ausführen wollen da ist power shell bestimmt schick aber ansonsten ist power shell als
interaktive shell irgendwie mist athias sagt wenn der 0850 linux wenn er 0850 nutze aber
er nur seinen web browser verwendet ja das ist auch ein gründer dafür spricht kann er auch auf
linux gehen immer einzige gründe für windows sind nur noch gaming und professionelle software
richtig und das sind aber halt nicht nicht einfach nur die allen aber nicht die einzigen gründe
sondern das sind riesengründe ja das ist es mögen zwar vielleicht wenig gründe an themengebieten
übrig sein aber das sind halt ziemlich ziemlich große und muss auch sagen die tun sich da unter
linux ein bisschen schwer das ist ja das wo ich auch immer rummeckere dass zum beispiel hardware
beschleunigung von videos im browser unter linux schlicht und ergreifend nicht beziehungsweise nur
mit sehr viel hex und dann auch nur unzureichend funktioniert und dann muss also du brauchst ja
dass das unter linux funktioniert brauchst du die richtige grafikkarte die richtige treiber die
richtige browser kombination und zusätzlich darf der anspruch auch nicht so groß sein dass du
vielleicht sogar vp9 oder web m oder irgendwas hardware accelerated haben willst das höchste
der gefühle ist richtige grafikkarte richtige browser patches sonst was installiert und dann
kannst du halt 264 videos gucken was aber nicht mehr die folgt ist unter wenn unter youtube
die meisten dm sachen funktionieren nicht genau wie gesagt spiele mit anti cheat ist auch vorbei
selbst wenn es irgendwie zum laufen kriegst linux hat während der corona krise stark zugelegt ja
das wundert mich allerdings nicht dass linux stark zugelegt hat erstens ist linux immer noch
in absoluten zahlen ziemlich wenig vertreten da ist es keine keine große kunst dass man groß dass
man wahnsinnige steigerungen hinkriegt und der hauptsächliche unterschied dürfte sein weil die
leute halt daheim sind weil die leute nicht windows verwenden müssen sondern halt daheim die
sachen verwenden können die sie wollen gehe ich mal ganz stark davon aus wenn du halt acht
stunden am tag auf der arbeit sitzt mit deiner windows kiste die dir halt vorgesetzt wird da
kannst du nicht verwenden was du willst und viele leute sind vielleicht auch eher auf dem linux
bereich zu hause und verwenden halt daheim der mehr linux aber das wundert mich nicht dass es
in der korona zeit ein bisschen zugenommen hat warum ist die halbzeit beschleunigen unter linux
so ein problem das liegt daran dass sie sich nicht so richtig einig werden also grundsätzliches
problem was was linux hat ist was grafische was was was was grafische anwendung angeht ist dass x
uralter haufen kacke ist das ist so ein ganz grundsätzliches problem was es unter linux gibt
und die alternativen also vor allem weyland die kommen ja auch nicht wirklich zu potte ja
und da streiten sie sich ja auch rum sowie wer ist jetzt an was schuld so und das ist
auch mal ein grundsätzliches problem die du unter windows unter linux grafisch immer hast
dass x ein riesen haufen alter kacke ist und die neuen alternativen irgendwie auch nicht besser
sind auch nicht richtig zu potte kommen so das nächste ist warum das mit den mit der video
beschleunigung so ein problem ist weil die grafikkarten hersteller kein bock haben das
richtig zu supporten das ist das nächste problem also sprich die open source treiber dies für die
meisten grafikkarten gibt die unterstützen halt nicht alle features die so eine grafikkarte hat
weil sie schlicht und ergreifend nicht wissen wie der kram funktioniert es gibt mittlerweile
wohl ganz gute open source treiber die besten sind von intel intel ist da seit jahren schon gut
dabei also die können wir mal ausnehmen aber sowohl wieder als auch amd haben halt probleme
mit open source treiber die kümmern sich die hersteller auch nicht großartig drum die denken
sich auch warum für die paar prozent an leute scheißen wir drauf das nächste ist selbst wenn
du intel hast und selbst wenn du den offiziellen wieder treiber nimmst der auch immer mal wieder
paar box hat dann hast du das nächste problem an welcher stelle muss das jetzt alles implementiert
werden also sprich der browser selbst muss in irgendeiner art und weise ja die hardware
ansprechen können für video beschleunigung so wie passiert das direkt direkt an die hardware
ist natürlich ein bisschen schwierig da müsstest du für jede erdenkliche os und hardware
implementierung irgendwie was eigenes in den browser einbauen das ist auch doof das heißt
die browser hersteller sagen jetzt ok eigentlich wollen wir das nicht eigentlich wollen wir
irgendwas verwenden was was was das betriebssystem anbieten irgendeine schnitt stelle dass man
halt bloß noch eine plattform unterstützen muss ja unter windows ist das relativ einfach
unter windows hast du das ganze direkt x geschiss und frag mich nicht wieder wie der ganze andere
kram heißt für für 3d geschichten und für encoding geschichten und unter linux hast du
wieder mehrere sachen ich glaube gibt drei verschiedene sachen so und also es gibt unter
linux gibt es einmal das da und es gibt noch auch wie ich weiß gar nicht wie der ganze
kram heißt das heißt die browser hersteller müssen erst mal gucken ficken fack was für
eine was für eine grafik schnitt stelle implement was für eine beschleunigung schnitt stelle
implementieren wir dann das muss der jeweilige grafikkarten treiber dann auch können und
dann streiten sie sich noch und das ist das nächste problem und dann streiten sie sich
noch an welcher stelle wer was machen muss und wer daran schuld ist dass irgendwas nicht
funktioniert das ist so die typische so die typische linux geschichte warum sachen so
ewig dauern und das ist wirklich ein problem
ja du hast recht einfach als ersatz ist halt müll es sei denn du hast glück und es funktioniert
einfach alles dann ist es super du hast unter linux halt oftmals die sache dass du keine
ahnung installierst das auf notebook es geht out of the box beim ersten boot alles top
wunderbar dann ist es deutlich einfacher als wie ich das mit linux machen müsste allerdings
sobald was nicht funktioniert hast du halt echt ein problem dann ist es meistens nicht
möglich oder nur mit eklichen hacks
streams aus der vm nähe easy killer schreibt da hat er auch nicht unrecht schreibt easy
killer schreibt das problem ist ja auch dass so viele in der linux community alles was
neu ist boykottieren weil das war schon immer so das ist teilweise wirklich so zuletzt hat
man das mit systemd gesehen und systemd hat viele sachen wo man sich über streiten kann
so das beste beispiel ist damals als es angefangen hat dass die hersteller gesagt haben es ist
eine doofe idee dass der normale user irgendwelche interrupt channels einstellen muss oder dass
die sachen einfach eingesteckt werden und funktionieren das ist eine das ist wäre eine
gute idee da haben da haben viele aus der linux community damals gesagt was plug and
play wer will denn so was haben keck weh wer braucht das denn also ich will doch einstellen
welche interrupt adresse meine soundkarte verwendet also wer das nicht kann da sollte
eh nicht an den computer gehen du hast halt leider sehr viele so radikale leute in oftmals
auch an entscheidenden positionen bei open source projekten die halt mit der einstellung
rangehen und dann ist kein wunder dass das für viele abschreckend wirkt also ich habe
auch schon oft die aussage gehört so nach dem motto ja wenn man wenn man dafür zu dumm
ist so nach dem motto hier gibt jetzt erstmal diese 30 kommando zeilen befehle ein und dann
machst du hier noch irgendwie einen speziellen modus auf der netzwerkarte an und dann kannst
du das ganze machen und wer dafür zu blöd ist er sollte ja auch gar kein computer benutzen
was ist das für das ist richtig beknacktes argument muss einfach gucken und weil ich
auch weil ich auch gerade im chat schon wieder die diskussion sehe läuft jetzt das besser
auf windows läuft jetzt das besser auf linux es gibt keine ultimative antwort drauf du
hast sachen die laufen schlicht und greifen deutlich besser auf windows und du hast sachen
die laufen schlicht da greifen deutlich besser auf linux deswegen geht es gar nicht darum
dass man sagt ja nur das eine oder nur das andere sondern das eine wo es seine stärken
hat und dann das andere wo es seine stärken hat und meinetwegen auch noch einen meck dabei
wo es seine stärken hat wozu warum muss man immer raus kriegen was ist allgemein das beste
es gibt bei kaum bei kaum irgendwelchen problemen dass man sagen kann ja all das ist allgemein
das beste es ist auch aktuell gerade wieder die diskussion so nach dem motto home office
ja oder nein so nach dem motto 56 prozent sind dagegen der rest ist dafür das ist was
vollkommen individuelles das gibt keine entscheidung ja das ist besser oder das ist besser und
das ist da ähnlich habe ich den chat ein bisschen ich nicht nicht weiter verfolgt erinnern
sie doch immer ein halb von x vor dem release die fragment fragmentation unterliegen ist
gleichzeitig das beste schlecht kann man so sehen ja in manchen bereichen würde ich
mir allerdings wünschen dass da mal ein bisschen mehr in einem strang ziehen würden fack ich
habe subscribers vergessen subscribes am start das gem train läuft auch leute das train ist
am start so den habe ich nie vergessen wertex hast du auch am start twitch prime ne tier
one huge wahnsinn exzellent so den haben wir dann sonst noch kofax twitch prime dankeschön
mr.
wipp aneht ist schon zwei tage her auch verguckt aber den fehler habe ich übersehen der ist
schon acht monate am start high iq chat wahnsinn und dann haben wir noch den stellzer der hat
auch re-subscribed der hat mir sogar das video geschickt für zwei monate wahnsinnige high
iq subscriptions heute wieder ok ich habe es den chat irgendwie ein bisschen fand ich muss
mal kurz chat runterscrollen dass ich wieder auf dem aktuellen stand bin
tschüss
ich wollte letzte woche den jungs auf meinem hauptrechner als dual boot installieren habe
drei stunden lang verschiedene usb sticks mit verschiedenen distros installe konnten
alle nicht booten ok das ist recht merkwürdig du hast deine dvd gebrannt ok das ist das
würde ich jetzt allerdings mal nicht auf die auf die installer schieben sondern eher dass
vielleicht dein efi bios was auch immer irgendwelche merkwürdigen sachen hat weil ich kann mich
nicht dran erinnern wo mal ein usb stick nicht gebootet hatten letzten 15 jahren
was sagst du zu chrome os habe ich noch nicht ausprobiert
ok gucken wir uns das video mal weiter an gucken wir uns das video weiter an was an was
er sonst noch zu sagen hat wo sind von stehen geblieben jetzt für linux im privatbereich
den übrig also mir fällt jetzt keins mehr ein doch moment da fällt mir eins ein ich glaube wenn
ich einen freunden streich spielen würde will ich den linux installier auf dem pc und dann sagen
dass kannst du echt machen du musst aber in den windows in den windows skin nehmen nimmst am
besten in den kde mit dem windows skin das machen ja auch die ganzen scam scam scammer also die die
sich quasi dann von irgendwelchen indischen scammer anrufen lassen und sich und dann die
innen auf innen vm mit linux verbinden lassen und dann sind die innen immer komplett am
verzweifeln und dann würde er sich ärgern und ich hätte meinen spaß ich meine man kann es
vergleichen ist es wie als würde ich einen kothaufen vor seinen haustür legen also das
fazit dazu linux ist halt wirklich nur was für leute die sich das system installieren
und halt im terminal rumzuspielen sich dabei einen abzuwixen aber ich meine es ist ein toll
video allerdings finde ich immer gut wenn man sich das anguckt weil da ist schon immer eine gewisse
gewisse wahrheit dabei ja so weit ist das manchmal gar nicht weg man wirklich keine leute
sorry was mich aber auch wundert dass so wenig kritische stimmen laut werden gegen linux ich
habe das stimm ich dass wenn man das macht man einfach von irgendwelchen fanboys ja das ist
das normal du wirst fanboys hätten immer gerne rum das ist normal sag mal xbox ist besser als
playstation was weißt du was da los ist weil linux ist ja gegen den mainstream das ist ja so cool
und zur krönung von dem ganzen die stadt münchen hat man darf nicht man darf nicht vergessen linux
ist in sehr vielen bereichen mainstream als winnows der einzige der einzige bereich wo
winnows halt wirklich relevant ist ist der normale desktop pc das komplette verwaltungsnetzwerk
inklusive alle arbeitsbc ja das ist nicht mehr aktuell das ist nicht mehr aktuell die wollen
jetzt wieder umstellen hatte das gesehen die wollen jetzt wieder umstellen die wollen jetzt
wieder von winnows weg an die techie abonniert twitch prime dankeschön huge subscription
high IQ subs heute das ist denn jetzt er rutsch weiter umzustellen das hat zehn jahre gedauert
bis es umgestellt wurde und schlussendlich ist das ist das zählt auch nicht wirklich es gibt
heute noch winnows xp rechner war gescheitert weil es einfach vorne und hinten probleme gab
ohne ende jetzt ist aktuell münchen auch wieder dabei auf winnows umzustellen wer sich da mal
informieren will unten in der video beschreibung ist die quelle dazu ich denke mal das ganze
spricht für sich aber zugegebenermaßen okay halt quellenangaben ist das video doch kein troll
welche wo ich linux mag sind der raspberry pi aber nur als grundlage für eine desktop virtualisierung
mit windows und android smart phones der raspberry pi als grundlage für eine desktop virtualisierung
mit windows ok das ist doch ein troll video das ist doch ein troll video die laufen ja auch
auf linux aber gott sei dank hat man nix davon so das war die tracks preview zu linux ich hoffe
ihr habt's gehofft bis dann ciao ok das muss ein troll video gewesen sein der mr prince alles
klar jetzt müssen wir trotzdem mal die comments angucken wie viele da drauf abgehen
die antworten die antworten da viel zu seriös drauf die eigentlich müsste man die comments
jetzt posten oder irgendwas da kann es doch gar nicht ernsthaft darauf antworten das ist
eindeutig ein troll video ok das das ist einer der hat sie überhaupt nicht gecheckt das ist
einer der hat sie überhaupt nicht gecheckt lol wie er sich aufregt weil er keine ahnung hat ja
ist wahrscheinlich der schorsch ist wahrscheinlich der richtige richtige pro glückwunsch zum
erfolglosen ab reagieren ein ernsthaftes für mein ja ich fand das video nicht schlecht es
war doch eindeutig ein absichtliches troll video allerdings durchaus mit einem funken
wahrheit drin was haben wir als nächstes ich habe meinen backofen gehackt was der erste
ist echt der beste ok linux ist also erste comment was hier linux ist für studenten und
arbeitslose während ihr in eurem drecksterminal rumklimpert prügele ich meine wunderschöne
freundin ahja alles klar anzeige ist raus so was haben wir als nächstes ich habe meinen
backofen gehackt schon gelesen dass das neue battlefield nicht battlefield 6 ach bügel
nicht prügel ohje leute die twitch polizei kommt gleich vorbei gleich ist gleich vorbei
gleich der channel weg leute schon gelesen dass das neue battlefield nicht battlefield
6 heißt nee habe ich noch nicht gelesen progressing very very well das ist ja das könnte ja 1
zu 1 auszug aus irgendeinem blog sein das ist das ist so die antwort also wer sowas
als antwort gibt ja also mal hier als haft das ist wie wenn ich auf der arbeit einer fragt
und wie gehts und wie gehts voran dann sagst du auch ja ziemlich gut ziemlich gut läuft
alles wunderbar das ist ich habe aber noch nicht rausgekriegt wo das steht mit das battlefield
6 nicht battlefield 6 heißen soll aber selbst wenn ich auch ok die battlefield benahmung
der reihe ist eh komplett im arsch
aber wie gesagt bei battlefield ist die benahmung eh komplett im arsch das heißt die können
es eigentlich gar nicht mehr komplizierter machen und alles nur weil die battlefield
eins dazwischen einstreuen mussten
ich heiße dann auch battlefield 23 für das ja oder so
der ist mir viel zu hyper aktiv
und und und schaffen wir und schaffen was irgendwie vielleicht mal nicht alle zwei minuten
einen cut zu machen zu wenig sauerstoff im raum das könnte auch sein ok wir spulen
mal ein bisschen vor da ist mir zu der ist mir zu hyper aktiv ich will sehen wo er den
ofen gehackselt hat hier gehts los für die ganzen leute mit fußfett ist
ich habe eine leute mit fußfett in die leute mit fußfett in die leute mit fußfett in die
leute mit fußfett in die leute mit fußfett in die leute mit fußfett in die leute mit fußfett
Und der größte ist dieser hier.
Es nennt sich ein Bakingsteel und es verwendet schnell einen Pizzastrom.
Eine bessere Heizkapazität, damit es mehr Heiz hält.
Aber es hat auch eine bessere Heizkonduktivität,
was bedeutet, dass es den Heiz mehr schnell zurückgeben wird.
Dann setze ich den Ofen auf Grillenmode
und lasse ihn für etwa 30 Minuten preheaten.
Ich weiß, dass es 300°C sagt.
Siehst du? 250°C.
Das ist nicht so schlimm, aber das ist definitiv nicht 300°C.
Wir haben ein Küchenproblem.
Hier habe ich das offizielle Dokument,
das von der Assoziation de Verac' per la Pizza Napoletana ausgeliefert wurde.
Das Küchen sollte exklusiv in einem Holzfeuerofen gemacht werden.
Ich werde diesen Teil abschneiden.
Der Ofen hat die Küchentemperatur von 485°C erreicht.
In so einem Ofen kannst du sogar Sachen löten.
9 oder 5°C Fahrenheit.
Die meisten Öfen gehen zu 250°C.
Die Technik kann gelernt werden.
Die Teigung kann gemacht werden.
Aber der Heiz kann nicht nur erzeugt werden.
Was ist mit dir los?
Was?
Okay, was genau hat er eigentlich vor?
Er will original italienische Pizza möglichst italienisch in seinem Ofen machen.
Oh, Windows 98 Seite.
Okay, er versucht jetzt den Ofen heißer zu kriegen als sonst.
Aber wenn du das wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich wenn die Tür gar nicht über den Schalter reindrück,
dann geht wahrscheinlich der Ofen nicht mehr an.
Hör mal auf.
Okay.
Wenn du ein Feuerhazard nicht machen willst, dann mach das nicht.
Wie gesagt, lasst uns einfach den F***er entfernen.
Was zur Hölle?
Ich denke, es gibt keine Rückkehr.
Lass uns nur auf meine Wahrnehmung sagen.
Wenn ich meinen Job richtig gemacht habe, sollte ich die Tür öffnen.
Auch wenn die Tür geschlossen ist.
3, 2, 1.
Ich bin sehr gespannt.
Ich bin interessiert, das ist das, was ich versucht habe.
Im Endeffekt habe ich noch einen Sicherheits-Futur auf meinem Ofen.
Sie wird mich töten.
Jemand muss das tun.
Ich habe diesen schlechten Junge mit mir.
Er bleibt mit mir alles in diesem Experiment.
Okay, ich muss dir etwas verrücktes zeigen.
Ich habe den Ofen 15 Minuten vorgeheizt.
Schauen wir uns die Temperatur an.
Ich hoffe, du bist bereit für das.
Du kannst nicht bereit sein für das.
425, 428.
428, exzellent.
Ich bin sehr nötig, um zu singen.
Der braucht jetzt noch so ein cooles Paddel.
Ich weiß nicht, wie das heißt.
Die Italiener haben immer noch so ein Paddel.
Weißt du, was ich meine? So einen Schieber.
So einen Schieber brauchst du da eigentlich noch.
Wow, 1 Minute und 30 Sekunden.
Wie soll ich eine Pizza in einer Domestik-Oferne in 1 Minute und 30 Sekunden kochen?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Der riecht gebrochen.
Nein.
Dann öffnen wir das.
Es riecht definitiv gebrochen.
Was ist das?
Ich habe ein Problem, um es zu lösen.
Wieso sieht das gut aus?
Na ja.
Ich habe ein komplettes Problem, um es zu lösen.
Oh.
Backpapier drunter?
Einer der schönsten Pies, die ich je gebacken habe.
Und dann öffnest du es.
Es ist komplett gebrochen.
Gebrochen?
Auch wenn das sehr gut aussieht.
Du hast so einen schönen Topf.
Aber dann hast du das.
Warum ist das so?
Ich habe den ganzen Episod für Heat gesucht.
Und jetzt habe ich zu viel Heat.
Es ist eine leichte Lehre.
Der Grund, warum ich meinen Pizza-Stone auf Pizza-Steam aufgeräumt habe.
Eigentlich eine größere Menge Heat in einer kurzen Zeit.
Und jetzt geht es um mich.
Kannst du das glauben?
Als wir näher kommen,
Ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert mit Backpapier.
Wir brauchen weniger Hilfe von Extra-Materialien.
Ich weiß, es klingt dumm.
Aber ich muss meine Steine ausprobieren.
Ich meine, du hast mein Gehirn gelesen.
Ich dachte, das wird mein Ofen nie wieder sehen.
Aber ich kann Schnitzel und Spaghetti machen.
Ich glaube, das wird ein bisschen mehr Heat brauchen als mein Backpapier.
30-45 Minuten.
Ein paar Minuten später habe ich eine Pizza gemacht.
Ich bin Sorgen.
Wenn ich diese aufstehe, habe ich keine andere Option.
Ich sollte das auch nicht öffnen.
Die Musik!
Ja! Ja, ja, ja, ja!
Jaaa!
So, das ist das, worüber ich spreche.
Charmars, aber nicht ein verbranntes Knopf.
Oh, das ist...
So, diese Krummstruktur
So, diese Krummstruktur setzt jetzt eine große Spine auf meinen Kopf.
Eine Sache, von der ich mich ein bisschen weniger stolz auf mache, ist das Schäumen der Pizza.
Sieht aber gut aus.
Ich gucke den meisten Leuten nicht gern beim ersten Tour.
Aber Pizza sieht gut aus.
Kann man nichts sagen.
Huge.
Okay, das gucken wir uns ja nicht nochmal an.
Das reicht jetzt.
Nvidia Shield TV Review.
Ah ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Auf das neue.
Das neue Shield TV sieht ja aus wie...
Ja, wie sieht das aus?
Wie eine Röhre, irgendwie.
Es sieht ziemlich schlecht aus.
Im Vergleich zum alten, finde ich.
Guckt euch das mal an.
Das alte Shield TV sah so aus.
So.
Das ist das alte Shield TV.
Und das neue ist jetzt so eine komische E-Zigarette.
Also, ich kann mir nicht helfen.
Aber ich finde, dass das alte Shield TV einfach viel besser ausgesehen hat als das neue.
Aber ja, gucken wir mal, was Linus dazu zu sagen hat.
Das neue ist so eine Wurst, genau.
Kommt noch Warzone Stream.
Jetzt wurde es öfters gespielt.
Oh, ich weiß nicht.
Also gestern haben wir eine Runde gewonnen.
Aber auch nur, weil ich richtig hardcore gecarried wurde.
Und danach waren ein paar ganz gute Runden dabei.
Noch, aber die meisten liefen nicht so gut.
Ja, einen Win habe ich jetzt.
Aber wie gesagt, ich wurde hardcore gecarried.
Vom Vertrez?
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man das richtig ausbricht, ehrlich gesagt.
Der ist auch gerade im Chat.
Wobei ich gucken würde, wenn ich High Octane Warzone Gameplay sehen wollte.
Was, Twitter?
Wins only.
Na klar, wir machen ja prinzipiell nur Wins only.
Linus, jetzt zeige uns mal, warum wir das jetzt brauchen.
Aus meiner Sicht 0 HD.
Dreimal darfst du raten, wer 0 HD ist auf diesem Bildschirm.
Guckt mal, unser Warzone-Win von gestern.
Ich zeige es euch mal.
Unser Warzone-Win von gestern.
Jetzt ratet mal, welcher von den drei ich bin.
Ich bin nicht MILF, Kilian.
Ich meine, vom Alter her würde es schon passen.
Aber natürlich ist allen klar, dass ich 0 HD bin.
So ein beknackter Name fällt nur den Max ein.
Und ich sage doch, ich wurde Hardcore gecarried.
Zwei Kills. Ich habe das Gameplay sogar aufgenommen.
Immerhin zwei Kills.
Massive.
Excellent.
Huge Kills.
Now is a perfect time to investigate Nvidia's claims about last year's new Shield TV.
Because it has an awesome feature called AI Upscaling,
which Nvidia claims can take lower quality content, let's say 1080p,
and with the power of machine learning, upscale said content to look like...
Ey, Upscaling beim Shield TV.
Da muss ich jetzt mal was loswerden.
Es ist mir vollkommen egal,
ob die da irgendwelches AI Machine Learning Geschiss Upscaling machen.
Das Upscaling des alten Shield TVs war absolut Bullshit.
Absolut richtig schlecht.
Ich habe selten so schlechtes Upscaling gesehen, wie das alte Shield TV hatte.
Also richtig schlecht.
Also sprich, wenn du normales, du hast 720p oder sag mal du hast 1080p zu 4K Upscaled,
es sah so dermaßen scheiße aus.
Und normalerweise erkennst du den Unterschied zwischen den einzelnen Upscalern gar nicht richtig.
Aber der Nvidia Shield, das Upscaling auf 4K beim alten Shield TV, das war so schlecht.
Das hast du richtig gesehen, ob der Fernseh Upscaled oder das Shield TV Upscaled.
Das ist die Pro, da hat die Wurst, ja.
Der hat nicht die Wurst, der hat das normale.
Ja, das ist Müll.
Ich habe ja schon einige Geräte gehabt, wo die CEC hatten.
Also sprich, dass es quasi die Fernseh, Fernbedienung, Sachen über HDMI an das Gerät überträgt.
Das geht, wenn man beispielsweise mal die Shield Fernbedienung nicht zur Hand hat
und dann das mit der Fernbedienung vom Fernseh machen kann, aber es leckt.
Es ist kacke.
Die Fernbedienung vom Gerät ist immer noch das Beste.
Zumal du auch nur mit der Fernbedienung vom Gerät gescheit Keys ummappen kannst.
Okay.
Ich habe gar keine Ahnung, was mein Nvidia...
Ich gucke mal kurz, was mein Nvidia Shield für wie viel RAM der hat.
Da müssen wir uns mal kurz per SSH drauf verbinden, wenn ich jetzt die IP von dem Ding wüsste.
Wie ist die IP von meinem Shield TV?
Ich muss mal kurz in meinen Router gucken.
Nee, ich habe dem Ding leider keinen DNS-Name gegeben. Hätte ich dem Ding einen DNS-Name gegeben,
dann wäre es einfacher gewesen hier.
Shield Tablet, Shield TV 2, 2, 4 hat es gerade.
Oh.
Hm.
Okay.
Der SSH-Säuber läuft nicht mehr. Dann logge ich mich da nicht drauf ein.
IP-Leak, Mocker-S.
Ja, ich habe den SSH-Säuber anscheinend nicht gestartet.
Nee, das Ding hat keinen SSH, aber du kannst eine Android-App installieren.
Ich habe immer.
Beste.
Denn da. Einfach das Ding auf jedes Android-Gerät drauf.
Dann hast du einen SSH-Säuber, hast ein ordentliches Linux drauf, wo du Kommandos halte,
wo du machen kannst, was du willst.
Beste Android-App muss auf jedes Android-Gerät drauf.
Was? Mocker-S.
Okay, der Controller ist tatsächlich ganz nice.
Okay.
Das Beste ist eh, wenn man wirklich ein low-Price, absolut ausreichendes Android-TV-Gerät haben will,
holt man sich im Weihnachtssale einen Firestick.
Ja, warum auch immer die Dreieckeck sein muss.
Halbe Toplerone sieht echt so aus.
Das hat echt was von der Toplerone-Packung.
Den hat meine mich.
Übrigens, ich zeige euch mal was.
Ich habe ja das alte Shield-TV mit dieser Fernbedienung.
Mit der. Die Fernbedienung ist okay, aber die hat ein bisschen wenig Buttons.
Außerdem hat die diesen komischen Google Assistant-Button drauf, den ich nicht brauche.
Aber ich habe den eh umgemappt.
Was man machen kann ist, wenn man sich sowas kauft, man kann sich beispielsweise einen Firestick kaufen.
Ob man nimmt die Firestick-Fernbedienung.
Die Firestick-Fernbedienung, die kannst du nämlich auch einfach per Bluetooth pairen mit deinem Shield-TV.
Und da hast du deutlich mehr Buttons.
Unter anderem kannst du auch vor- und zurückspulen.
Du hast die ganzen Android-Buttons drauf, was ich deutlich angenehmer finde.
Und das Shield-TV in Kombination mit der Firestick-Fernbedienung finde ich ziemlich gut.
Und preislich auch echt günstig, wenn man eh noch einen Firestick haben möchte.
Sonst natürlich nicht.
Ja, das habe ich alles ausgeplendet.
Das habe ich alles ausgeplendet.
Ich hoffe auch, das AI ist Cloud-Enabled Big Data Function as a Service.
Und Blockchain.
Auf Docker, genau.
Moment, was?
Was?
Ich sehe keinen Unterschied.
Wartet mal.
Ja.
Sowas kann man aber auch schlecht in einem Video erkennen.
Ich sehe echt keinen Unterschied.
Doch, es ist unten ein bisschen schärfer.
Es ist unten ein bisschen schärfer, wie auf der anderen Seite.
Aber das kann man auch schlecht in einem Video erkennen.
Okay, hier erkennt man echt was.
Was ich mich frage ist, ist das jetzt ein gesponsertes Video von Nvidia?
Beziehungsweise gibt es da, gibt es da Money für oder reviewt das einfach nur so?
Okay, ich sehe keinen Unterschied.
Big Brain Upscaling.
Costa 250, nein, das braucht man nicht.
Das ist eher so, ich würde sagen, das Feature ist sowas, wo man sich nicht, also man kauft sich nicht das Gerät für dieses Feature.
Es ist eher so ein Feature, das gibt so den Ausschlag für das Gerät anstatt für ein anderes.
Oder wenn man es eh schon hat, freut man sich, dass es das Feature gibt.
Ich glaube nicht, dass es jemand gibt.
AI Upscaling, das ist der Grund, warum ich mein Equipment Upgrade jetzt und das neue Shield TV kaufe.
Das stimmt, ich bin echt, ich bin extrem zufrieden bei Shield TV.
Und von den wenigen Zeiten, in denen Jake Nvidia Game Stream versuchte, hat es perfekt funktioniert.
Und wahrscheinlich der größte Standout, den er sagt, ist, dass die Probleme mit seinem alten Chromecast oder Xbox One, oder eigentlich habe ich diese Probleme mit meinem PC vorher auch,
wo ein bestimmtes Video Codex für keinen Grund bäufig wird oder der Content langsam zu starten wird.
Das stimmt, der Kram funktioniert wirklich gut.
Welche Vorteile hat das Shield gegenüber dem Firestick von Amazon?
Ich würde sagen, vom Betriebssystem her nicht wirklich viel.
Es ist im Prinzip auch Android TV, halt bei dem einen die Amazon Variante.
Das Schöne ist, dass das hier ein ziemliches Stock Android TV ist und dass die Hardware vom Shield TV vermute ich eine ganze Ecke stärker ist.
Als vom Firestick. Ich habe jetzt aber keinen Vergleich dazwischen.
Kann ich mit dem Firestick endlich vernünftig Twitch auf dem TV schauen?
Also wenn es dafür eine Twitch App gibt, schon.
Ich habe meinen Firestick noch hier liegen. Keine Ahnung.
Das erste, was man mit den Amazon Android Geräten eigentlich erstmal machen muss, ist in der Regel erstmal deep-loaden.
Also sprich erstmal ganze Amazon Werbung runterschmeißen.
Ohje, wir sind ja hier auf einer Amazon-Plattform. Ich hoffe, ich darf das überhaupt sagen.
Wofür braucht man gute Hardware bei einem TV?
Zum Beispiel für Upscaling, in dem Fall mit AI-Geschiss und sonst was.
Oder aber, dass sich das Menü schön flüssig anfühlt.
Oder, dass du 4K-Sachen ordentlich abspielen kannst.
Dass du übers Netzwerksachen ohne Geruckel abspielst.
Was immer. Also mehr RAM und mehr Power schadet dir in der Regel nie.
Vielleicht willst du auch irgendwas transcoden beim Abspielen?
Ja, sehe ich auch so.
Jetzt erschreckt mich das so.
Ja, kann ich aber auch nur empfehlen.
Ich habe jetzt das Ding schon seit...
Wann habe ich das?
Kannst du mich sagen?
Da hatte ich es nämlich schon eine Weile.
Hier, also ich habe das schon ein bisschen länger als drei Jahre.
Ich vermute mal dreieinhalb.
Weil, als ich das Video gemacht habe, da hatte ich schon die Hintergrundbeleuchtung an.
Das sieht man jetzt nicht, weil es Tag ist.
Da hatte ich es dann wahrscheinlich...
Ach, hier sieht man es doch.
Hier war Kodi 17.11 angesagt.
Also ich denke mal, dass ich es ungefähr dreieinhalb Jahre jetzt schon habe.
Hier das Setup mit dem Shield-TV.
Ich habe übrigens Nvidia-Schuhe, wo wir gerade beim Thema sind.
Das fällt mir gerade auf.
Und das funktioniert wirklich gut.
Also ich kann das nur empfehlen.
Ich kann das echt nur empfehlen, das Shield-TV.
Das ist wirklich super.
Aber das stimmt tatsächlich, wie Nilos das gesagt hat.
Es funktioniert einfach...
Oh, Max liegt.
Liegt.
Wieder mal.
Da ist er.
Man sieht mal ein Mikrofon davor.
Okay.
Übrigens an alle TV-Jose, holt euch Sound-TV-App.
Ist eine viel bessere App um Twitch zu...
Was ist das? Kenne ich nicht.
Sound-TV-App.
Sagt mir gar nichts. Was ist das?
Oh, LeadSpeak schon mal.
Ah, okay.
Eine bessere Twitch-App.
Hat die Adblock?
Ja.
Hat die Adblock drin?
Das ist das, was mich da interessieren würde.
Weil ich bin die ganze Zeit schon auf der Suche nach einer guten Twitch-App für Android mit Adblock.
Das muss ich haben, wenn ein Null im Namen ist.
Ja, das ist eindeutig. Das ist Elite.
Oh, was haben wir sonst noch hier?
Wir gucken jetzt, Leute, wir gucken jetzt ein paar Battlefield-Top-Plays.
Da haben wir schon lange nicht mehr geguckt.
Twitch-Turbo ist ein guter Adblock.
Ich will mir keinen Twitch-Turbo kaufen.
Oh, der Sound von Battlefield 3 war einfach huge.
Das hört sich so gut an, die Waffensounds in dem Game.
Das Battlefield 4 sieht doch eh alles gleich aus auf Metro.
Was sind das denn für Pepega-Gegner? Was machen die da hinten?
Was? Was?
Moment, was machen die da? Was treiben die in der Ecke?
What the fuck?
Hello and welcome to the Battlefield-Top-Plays.
In today's episode we're taking a look at Battlefield 3 and Battlefield 4.
Some of the best moments that I've been sent in over the past few weeks.
That intro clip was absolutely amazing.
Moving on, we have Dominator666 with one of his pretty incredible Battlefield 3 moments.
Warum kriegt die kein gescheites Battlefield, man?
Macht ihr einfach mal wieder ein gutes Battlefield.
Ich hätte so Bock, ein ordentliches Battlefield zu spielen.
Oh, was gibt denn das? Crossbow-Trickshot hier.
Wow, okay, mehr Glück als Verstand, aber hat gehitted.
I bet you never thought this was possible.
Dominator666 does hit some mega clips.
Major Turtle sagt gerade, ich habe voll die Sorgen, dass die Performance beim nächsten Battlefield so kacke sein wird wie bei Battlefield 5.
Ich muss sagen, die letzten Battlefields, die liefen verdammt gut bei Release.
Ich hatte überhaupt keine Schmerzen mit.
Aber gut, man muss sagen, es wäre ja auch Fail, hätte ich Schmerzen mit.
Weil, zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, der 8700k und die 1080ti so mit das beste Setup waren, was du haben konntest.
Ja, wäre ja auch bescheuert, wenn ich da ein Problem hätte.
Ja, stimmt schon. Kann ich eigentlich gar nichts zu sagen.
Terox sieben Monate lang schon. Excellent. Subscription.
Was war da denn jetzt so incredible?
Oh, da kommt da jetzt noch was.
Da kommt noch was.
What the fuck? Wackel, wackel, wackel, wackel.
Okay, das ist Glück, wenn das trifft. Ich meine es trifft, aber das ist Glück.
Das ist Glück. Da erzählt mir keiner Predicted. Da kann mir keiner erzählen Predicted, Alter.
M.
Ich habe so Pepe in der Gegner wieder.
Die Videos sind Metro-Locker-Nosha-Kennels-TDM. 90% der Videos.
LMG legit.
Deniz Unleashed ist bald fertig. Ich gucke da öfters mal ins Forum rein.
Und das hat sich seit drei Jahren irgendwie nichts mehr getan.
Was macht der Gegner denn da?
Was? Moment.
Was machen die da? Gucken die sich die Wand an?
Also praying, der hat Gegner wieder.
Okay, das hittet ihr jetzt. Aber nur weil der Heli absolut keine Anstattung.
Ist das staged? Der ist ja voll reingeflohen, der Heli.
Hieß der echt so? Moment, das muss ich mal gucken.
Wie hieß der? Moment.
Wo? Wo steht's?
Der Autokokker.
Genau.
Der ist bestimmt gestaged, der Clip.
Und wieder in den Jetride. Perfekt.
So Clips gucke ich mir irgendwie gern an. Die sind zwar komplett banal, aber es bringt auch meistens nichts.
Das ist nichts, aber es ist nice zu sehen.
Keine Leute auf dem Server, ja.
Aber trotzdem cool.
Last nice FPG.
Erstmal eine Runde.
Da stehen sie unten drin.
Ah.
So dieses permanente Gefühl, dass das Omnistromerom die Kacke am Dampfen ist, hast du nur in Battlefield 3 und 4 gehabt.
Der absolute PP-Gang-Gegner wieder am Start.
Destruction by the enemy.
Ich habe immer noch Medic Train gespielt, nach dem Zuma-Engineer.
Next up, it's clearly, and he's gonna be playing on Gulin Peaks. Calling it Boomer. Boomer incoming.
Ich wusste gar nicht, ich hab das noch nie gesehen.
Ich wusste gar nicht, dass es den gibt auf der Map.
Den man teilweise noch nie gesehen hat, das hätte durchaus länger am Leben gehalten werden können.
And the thing goes krrrrr.
Ja scheinbar wird's immer noch gespielt, ja.
Weil es ja auch das letzte verbliebene Battlefield ist, was man sich noch geben kann.
Jetzt schreckt.
Was? DIGZO?
Ist das Konsole? Nee oder? Ist nicht Konsole, aber es ist einfach nur komisches Seitenverhältnis.
Er ist mal in den Arsch geschockt. Die Gegner! Alter, was ist mit uns los?
Die Gegner haben sich einfach alle umgedreht. Die haben sich einfach alle umgedreht, als er ins Bild gekommen ist.
Keck W!
G18 war echt eine nice Waffe in dem Game.
Alter, du blickst ja überhaupt nicht mehr durch, was gerade um dich herum passiert.
Bei dem Ding musst du zu viel nachladen, den wage ich irgendwie nicht.
Der lädt auch nach jedem Magazin, äh nach jedem Schuss.
Ah, yes, Metro.
Ok Mango, gucken wir uns Flashbacken an.
Ah, ich guck die Videos immer gern.
Battlefield 3 und 4, das ist sowas, vor allem Battlefield 3, da hab ich immer nice Erinnerungen dran.
Und ich bin jedes Mal immer so enttäuscht, wie wenig mir die letzten Teile gefallen haben.
Angefangen mit Battlefield 1 und jetzt Battlefield 5. Was ein kleiner Blick in Venice Unleashed, ja das können wir uns jetzt mal angucken kurz noch schnell.
Da ist Danny und Today.
Das ist doch irgendwie tot oder interessiert sich doch auch keiner mehr dafür.
Ich mein die Sache wäre richtig cool, es wäre richtig nice, wenn sie es schaffen würden, Battlefield 3, 4 und Hardline irgendwie so zugänglich zu machen.
Also sprich, dass man daraus quasi alles aus diesen Games zusammenpacken kann, das wäre schon cool.
Und ich würde mir wünschen, dass es wirklich ein bisschen Fahrt aufnimmt, aber das ist ja schon wie gesagt 5 Jahre oder so in Entwicklung und am Start.
Das interessiert sich glaube ich mittlerweile keine Sau mehr dafür.
Ich hoffe ja, dass das gut funktioniert. Wieso ist dein Google-Symbol blau, weil es Chromium ist?
Ich mal gucken, ist das komplett dead?
Das Forum ist dead, das Reddit ist dead, ah GitHub.
Sexy as 6 years ago, Twitter ist auch mehr oder weniger dead, Discord ist voll.
Ja mal gespannt, also mal gucken, es wäre auf jeden Fall cool, wenn es Battlefield 3, 4 und Hardline so irgendwie in einem Paket vereint wiederbeleben würde.
Da würde ich wieder den ganzen Tag Battlefield grinden und DICE würde sich denken, oh WTF, wie kann das sein, dass die Leute die Spiele mögen und die neuen nicht so.
Was macht der denn da für Dinger?
Der löte die USB-Dinger um, was auch immer.
Black Ops 2 is fixed and playable, warum sollte es das nicht mehr sein, ich weiß halt nicht, ob es noch viele spielen.
Ah nee, Essen Video gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an.
What Battlefield 6 needs, das gucken wir uns mal an.
Mal gucken, was er dazu ablässt.
Bei wem? Costa, wem meinste?
Genau, Battlefield 6 braucht Skill-based Matchmaking.
Das hat noch gefehlt, Alter.
Was? Nächstes Jahr schon?
Was? Was? Was?
Moment, was?
Soll ich mal lachen?
Ist klar, ist klar, alles, hat man gesehen, hat man bei Battlefield 5 gesehen, wie gut das funktioniert hat.
Battlefield 4 haben sie das richtig gut gemacht, auch mit ihren Public-Test-Servern, alles, da sag ich nichts, aber danach war das doch voll für'n Arsch.
Ich mein, wie kann es sein, dass der ehemalige DICE-Chef sagt, wenns euch nicht gefällt, kauft euch nicht, das ist marketingtechnisch absoluter Fail.
Dann anfängt mit, ja aber wir stehen auf der richtigen Seite der Geschichte, was hat das mit Wir hören auf die Community zu tun?
Ich bin komplett an dem vorbeigefahren, was die Leute haben wollten.
Ich weiß nicht, wie dick Level-Cap noch ist mit den EA DICE Leuten, aber ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass er schon weiß, was das nächste Battlefield wird.
Ich bin der Meinung, ich sag's ja schon ganz lange, es gibt zwei Sachen, die ich gerne hätte.
Ich hätte ganz gerne mal wieder einen Modern Warfare-Game in der, sagen wir mal, jetzt Zeit vielleicht ein bisschen davor, ein bisschen danach.
Also ich find's okay, wenn die ein oder anderen Drohnen rumfliegen, aber ganz so futuristisch muss es nicht sein.
Was ich persönlich gerne hätte, ist ein Spiel in dem Dreh 1980, 1990, vielleicht Pan 70 rum, so quasi ungefähr in der Ära, wo Black Ops 1 gespielt hat.
Allerdings, dass sie ein komplettes Alternative Reality-Szenario nehmen.
Also sprich, dass die einfach nur die Ausgangslage nehmen, wie die Stimmung damals so war und quasi dann passiert irgendwas, was in echt nicht passiert ist.
Falls sich noch irgendeiner dran erinnert, hat jemand Command & Conquer Alarmstufe Rot gespielt, da ging's ja auch mehr oder weniger um den Zweiten Weltkrieg.
Nur, dass der Zweite Weltkrieg halt so nie stattgefunden hat.
Danach haben die Russen dann den Zweiten Weltkrieg angefangen und sonst was.
Also sprich, die haben auch ausgangsmäßig die Lage genommen und haben da ein bisschen was drumherum gesponnen.
Wobei man sagen muss, die Command & Conquer Stories mit den Zwischensequenzen, die war schon immer Hardcore-Cringe.
Aber sowas kann ich mir richtig gut vorstellen, weil das hätte den großen Vorteil, du könntest nahezu alles machen.
Du musst dich an nichts halten.
Du könntest eine Battlefield-Karte auf dem Mond meinen Wegen sogar dabei einbauen.
Du könntest einfach alles machen.
Und alles machen können ist ein riesen Vorteil, weil die Leute sich kreativ voll auslassen können.
Das stimmt. Das ist aber in allen Battlefield-Teilen, in allen Call of Duty...
Mir fällt eigentlich, machen wir es mal umgedreht, fällt euch ein Spiel ein, wo es customizable Waffen gibt in der Art und Weise wie Battlefield.
Und wo die Ingame-Beschreibung der Attachments der Realität entspricht.
Ich meine, denk mal zurück an Call of Duty, da hast du ein Visier auf die Waffe gemacht.
Und die haben gesagt, ja, ihre Waffe ist jetzt genauer geworden.
Aber totaler Schwachsinn, das Visier hat absolut nichts geändert.
Escape vom Tarkov, stimmt das wirklich?
Den habe ich nicht gespielt.
Okay, excellent, da gibt es wenigstens ein Game, wo das Sinn ergibt.
Ah, yes, plus 1337 IQ pro Monat auf meine IAL-Satz.
Excellent, hast du recht, genauso ist es.
Neo-Nominus, danke schön für den Sub.
Huge, big brain.
Call of Honor Warfighter, das glaube ich nicht, dass sie da gestimmt haben.
Okay, okay.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt nichts, was ich unbedingt hoch priorisieren würde bei Battlefield 6.
Dass man da gut Kid-Videos drüber machen kann.
Und also, es wäre schön, ein bisschen mehr Depth und Nuance zurück in die Battlefield-Franchise zu bekommen.
Nun, wenn es um die Handlung von Waffen im nächsten Spiel geht, denke ich, dass Battlefield 5 ziemlich gut gemacht hat.
Und obwohl Battlefield 5 viele Probleme hat, war die Handlung von Waffen im nächsten Spiel nicht der größte Problem.
Keine Suppression, die Recoil-Pattern, ein schnappiger und responsiver Schuss.
Es fühlte sich einfach richtig an.
Sobald ich den Gunplay-Systems von Battlefield 3 und Battlefield 4 mag, denke ich wirklich, dass Battlefield 5 darauf verbessert wurde.
Es gab jeder Waffe ein ziemlich distinctes Gefühl.
Man könnte sagen, dass Battlefield 4 nicht wirklich so gut gemacht hat.
Das heißt, sie könnten es ein bisschen weiter steigern.
Es gibt wirklich feste Recoil-Patternen, die sehr dedicated Spieler für Präzision, Akku und automatischen Schuss machen können.
Es könnte ein cooles Modell sein, um das exzellente Schuss auf den Gunplay zu geben.
Ich denke, feste Recoil-Patternen passen irgendwie nicht in Battlefield.
Das war eigentlich das Beste für Battlefield bisher.
Ich denke, es könnte ein bisschen mehr Spaß machen, wenn man mehr Schuss aufbaut, wie Flamethrowers oder Katanas von Battlefield 5.
Wenn es um die Klassen und was sie auf Battlefield gemacht haben, denke ich, ein paar Spiele haben eine bessere Arbeit gemacht als Battlefield 1.
Sie haben die Möglichkeit, Leute in ihren bestimmten Rollen zu exzellieren.
Aber sie haben auch die Möglichkeit...
Wenn ein Tank auf dem Feld rollt und du ein Sniper bist...
Dann gibt es eine Chance, dass du etwas hast, das du mit dem Kampf kontributen kannst.
Die Sniper hatten K-Bullets, die sich mit den Fahrzeugen zerstören konnten.
Du fühlst dich also nicht total unnötig.
Aber du warst noch nicht eine Klasse für nahe Quartierkombatt.
Du kannst nur kontributen, wenn du es wirklich brauchst.
Oder du fühlst dich, als hättest du...
Ja, da ist was dran.
Und das war mein Lieblingspart von Battlefield 1.
Schöne Rollen, sehr spezielle Ziele für jede Klasse.
Und trotzdem konnten sie alle...
Es gab noch eine Klasse in Battlefield 1, da hat es ja sogar noch eine Klasse mehr.
Rein für Demolition.
... immer noch in jeder Situation.
Das war etwas, das wirklich in Battlefield 5 ging.
Einige Klassen konnten einfach nichts mit den Fahrzeugen machen.
Und also fühlst du dich für eine große Menge des Spiels unnötig.
Es war komplett unnötig, wenn ein Tank aufsteht und du denkst, du wirst jetzt sterben.
Oder du musstest einfach so schnell wie möglich rennen.
In Battlefield 5, glaube ich, hat DICE wirklich ihren Weg verloren,
wenn es um Fahrzeugbalancen kam.
Ja, hat mir auch nicht gefallen, ich hab's ja nur in die Beta gespielt und da ging mir das schon auf den Sack.
In Battlefield 5? Weiß nicht, schwer zu sagen, dafür hab ich zu wenig gespielt.
Ja, Fahrzeuge waren zu gut.
Auch so eine komische Geschichte, dass die Flugzeuge in der Luft gespawnt sind.
Und so war es irgendwie auch ganz merkwürdig.
Gut, da kann ich nichts zu sagen. Dafür hab ich nicht genug gespielt.
In Battlefield 6, wir brauchen wieder ordentliches Rush mit richtig guten Maps.
Richtig abwechselnd, so was wie Demoman Peak zum Beispiel.
Das Gameplay ist mega PP gehalter.
Ein Killschnitt, ein Killschnitt.
Ja, irgendwie ist das Video doof. Das hätte man schöner machen können, was Battlefield 6 haben sollte, dass es wieder ein gutes Game wird.
Battlefield 6 sollte, wenn ich eine Sache nennen müsste, eine Sache, die das Spiel wieder richtig rausstechen lässt.
Das ist das, was für mich Battlefield 6 ausmacht.
Battlefield 6 sollte so eine Sache haben, wo du sagen willst, ja, das macht für mich Battlefield 6 aus.
Zum Beispiel, wo man sagen könnte, ja, für mich in Bad Company 2 waren es eindeutig Rush und die Rush Maps.
Das ist das, was Bad Company ausgemacht hat. Klar, du kannst noch viel mehr sagen.
Du kannst sagen, ja, du kannst dich nicht hinlegen. Du konntest beispielsweise nur langsamer moveen.
Du hattest irgendwie ein schwereres Gefühl bei den Waffen.
Es gibt viele Details, aber bei den meisten Spielen, die mir richtig gut gefallen haben, gibt es immer so einen Punkt,
wo ich sagen kann, ja, das ist der Punkt, der für mich das Spiel irgendwie mit ausmacht.
Bei Bad Company 1, Bad Company 2 kann ich sagen, ja, eindeutig die Rush Maps.
Battlefield 3 ist tatsächlich schwierig, eine Sache festzumachen.
Das ist so die Begeisterung des Gesamtpakets irgendwie in Battlefield 3 gewesen.
Ja, und das braucht Battlefield 6. Irgendso ein Punkt, der raussticht, wo du sagst, jawoll, das ist geil und das macht für mich Battlefield 6 aus.
Maps mit einem guten Wiederspiel, klar.
Zum Beispiel, das ist ja was, weil ich in den letzten Tagen relativ viel Modern Warfare gespielt hab.
Der Modern Warfare Multiplayer ist scheiße.
Der Modern Warfare Multiplayer rein von den Mechanics her, muss ich sagen, ist gar nicht so schlecht.
Die Maps sind so abgrundtiefer Dreck.
Es gibt ein paar Maps, die sind ganz okay, aber der Rest ist so unglaublich scheiße.
Ich weiß gar nicht, was mit denen los ist.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man auf solche Maps kommt.
Modern Warfare 2019 Maps, gibt's da eine schöne Übersicht.
Wahrscheinlich hab ich selbst noch gar nicht alle gespielt.
Alter, übelster Shit.
Dieses Warehouse, übelster Shit.
Übelster Shit.
Asier Cave.
Ich überleg grad, ob das die Map ist, die ich gestern gespielt hab, die so richtig räudig ist.
Ich glaube schon.
Ist das die mit der Mauer in der Mitte?
Weiß ich nicht.
Crash, gute Map.
Die Remake Maps sind alle gut.
Die Remake Maps sind alle...
Krass, scheiß Map.
Gunrunner ist okay.
Hangnair geht auch.
Scheiß Map.
Sagt mir jetzt nix.
Doch, das ist die.
Auch Scheiß Map.
Die Mutter aller Scheiß Maps.
Die größte Crap Map, die sie jemals erstellt haben.
Was war das hier nochmal?
Sagt mir nix.
Warum an Ausgängen Rust und Shipman Remake muss, ist doch lächerlich.
Mini Maps, die keinerlei spielerischen Mehrwert haben.
Shoot House ist okay.
Shoot House geht.
Shoot House ist genau die richtige Call of Duty Map Größe mit genau dem richtigen Call of Duty Map Layout.
So uninspiriert und schlecht, wie die Map aussieht, ist die tatsächlich so ganz gut.
Die sagt mir jetzt gar nix.
Das ist eine Remake Map, die ist okay.
Das ist auch okay.
Das ist eine Remake Map.
Aber der Rest, das können wir hier schon mal komplett knicken.
Nightmaps spielt kein Mensch.
Two-on-two Maps.
Also, da fängt er nochmal an.
Das Ding geht.
Geht, ist ganz gut.
Ist okay.
Ist auch okay.
Haben wir nicht gespielt, keine Ahnung.
Geht auch irgendwo absoluter Shit.
Hill, so eine Drecks Map.
King ist auch keine solle tolle Map.
Pyne auch Drecks Map.
Rust spielt sich ganz gut auf dem Modus.
Shipman auch.
Speedball ist ziemlich gut für Two-on-two.
Und Stack ist auch ganz okay.
Keine Ahnung.
Habe ich zu wenig gespielt.
Am besten finde ich ja die Warzone Maps.
Die sie so schön zu kosten haben, copypasted haben.
Schön sieht die Warzone Map auch nicht aus.
Muss man mal ehrlich sagen.
Eine schöne Map ist es nicht.
Es ist eher sehr zusammengeschustert.
Aber es funktioniert.
Ansonsten könnte der Multiplayer ganz gut sein.
Aber die Maps sind dermaßen schlechter.
Okay, was haben wir hier?
Black Ops 2 ist fixed and playable.
Warum sollte es nicht playable sein?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Warum sollte es?
Okay.
Ah, ich erinnere mich wieder.
Über den Theatermodus, über das Kino,
kannst du das Game exploiten.
Vom Spinboard bis zu allem Möglichen.
Ja, genau.
Ich erinnere mich.
Man konnte über den Kino-Modus das Game klitschen.
Aber es hat auch im Multiplayer funktioniert.
Für wie lange?
Seit vier Jahren oder so?
Okay, ich erinnere mich.
Ein bisschen lag.
So far so good, guys.
So far so good.
UAV in.
Okay, ich glaube, die Jungs...
Oh!
Ich glaube, die Jungs...
So far so good.
Das hat damit wahrscheinlich gar nichts zu tun.
Wahrscheinlich einfach nur, weil es faule Säcke sind.
Ich frage mich zum Beispiel auch,
warum kann man keine Maps voten?
Warum kann man in Modern Warfare keine Maps voten?
Das ist total hängen geblieben.
80% der Maps sind Bullshit.
Da lassen die Leute noch wenigstens die Maps voten, die gut sind.
Oder würde es dann quasi in der Statistik eindeutig sich niederschlagen,
dass eure Maps Bullshit sind?
So far so good.
Nice, bloodthirsty.
Wie genau hat das denn funktioniert?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Dabei hätten sie geschreddert.
Typischer Call of Duty-Tot von hinten.
Ist ein Koster.
Controller-Aim.
Für Controller-Aim ist das ziemlich okay.
Ziemlich, ziemlich gut.
Okay, dude, ich zerstreife diese Kinder.
Siehst du, wie viel besser das Spiel ist,
als wenn niemand verdammt Mods mit Unfaire-Aimbot und Silent-Aimbot
und so weiter geht?
Jedes Spiel ist besser ohne Cheater.
Ich glaube, es sind alle Trash-Spieler, die das auch benutzen.
So machen sie diese Art von Sachen.
Und dann glaube ich, dass sie gut sind.
Jetzt, wenn du endlich legit spielen kannst,
kannst du sie einfach ausbreiten.
Okay, ich bin verdammt.
Ich muss das Kaster töten.
Geh, geh, geh, geh, geh.
Ein bisschen Lack.
Das ist okay.
Ich bin 17 und 1.
Verdammt.
Oh mein Gott.
Der Splitscreener hat mich so bemerkt.
Glaubst du mir?
Also, außer der Lack in diesem Spiel,
ist alles okay.
Lock-Ups 2 sind legit.
Ich bin gerade hinter allen.
Da ist ein 4-Piece.
Das stimmt nicht.
Irgendjemand hat im Chat gerade gesagt,
dass Theater-Modus nur in Black Ops drin war.
Ich glaube, Modern Warfare 3 hatte auch einen Theater-Modus.
Oh.
Sprehen, drehen.
Das ist ein guter Spiel.
Oder ein Lack darum.
Wisst ihr, was an dieser Map,
ich bin kein großer Fan jetzt dieser Shipmap,
aber was man daran auch schon ganz gut sieht,
ist, es ist wichtig,
dass eine Map halbwegs im Hirn zu erfassen ist.
Und das ist das Problem bei den allermeisten Modern Warfare Maps.
Du kannst wirklich aus 20 Winkeln gepiekt werden.
Und in Modern Warfare ist es wirklich gepiekt.
Da läuft dir nicht einer entgegen aus 20 verschiedenen Richtungen,
sondern der Head klitscht am Fenster.
Und du läufst um die Ecke, bam, bist tot.
Du weißt gar nicht, dass er da ist.
Du kannst das hier halbwegs kontrollieren.
Du kannst von da einer kommen, durch Fenster einer kommen
oder von hinten einer kommen.
Das war's.
Wenn du da noch eine Claymore rechts hinstellst,
dann weißt du zumindest, okay,
es kann eigentlich nur noch einer sehr risikoreich
durchs Fenster kommen oder die Treppe.
Das ist wichtig.
Wie sollst du sonst sowas überhaupt halbwegs kontrollieren spielen?
Ich meine, Call of Duty ist an sich schon
so ein übelst krasses Random-Game im Multiplayer.
Und wenn du dann die Maps auch noch komplett random hast,
komplett knicken,
dann kannst du wirklich bloß noch entweder hirnlos draufrennen
und machst trotzdem viele Kills,
aber hast auch gleichzeitig viele Tode.
Oder du schimmelst dir halt den Hinternwund am Fenster.
But other than that, patching the theater mode mods means so much.
They got to pick a new host of this game.
They destroyed their satchel charge, but didn't kill him.
Shock charge, my bad.
Why does it say satchel charge?
Shock charge?
Shock dart, shock dart.
Das klappt immer.
Es gibt kaum einen Shooter, wo das nicht funktioniert.
Leg dich um die Ecke und es läuft einer rein, überall.
Das ist genauso wie am Treppenaufgang warten.
Das klappt auch in jedem Game.
Die kriegen aber gut auf den Sack gehen.
Straßen überqueren in Modern Warfare.
Das müssen wir uns gleich mal angucken.
Die haben sogar noch Voice Chat an die Leute.
Was ist denn da los?
Die Gegner bepegern.
Die Gegner bepegeln.
Du kannst schlecht irgendwo sitzen, weil dann verlierst du.
Gerade CS und Valiant ist ähnlich.
Man könnte schon sagen, dass das ziemlich viel Gekämpe ist.
Kämpfe ist. Aber ist es gar nicht, weil es ein Unterschied ist, ob man
Afraid ist, dass man gepiekt werden kann und deswegen in der Ecke steht und selbst hat klitscht und in eine Richtung schaut, in der Hoffnung es läuft mal
Einer durch. Das ist die Call of Duty Geschichte. In CS und Valorant ist es ja eher so, du
Du schließt ja aus, was auf der Map gerade
Möglich ist, in dem du dich langsam vorwärts bewegst oder auch wartest, weil du weißt, okay der Gegner kann jetzt nur noch in diesem Gang sein
Warum sollte ich den Gang pieken, wenn er zu mir kommen muss und so was. Das ist ein komplett anderes
Andere andere Art von Campen, wie das in Modern Warfighter der Fall ist
Was hältst du eigentlich von Valorant? Ich hab's nicht gespielt. Ich kenn's nur aus Streams. Ich guck mir Streams ganz gerne an, weil es für mich
eine schöne Kombination ist aus 90% CS und 10% ein bisschen Overwatch
Das finde ich nämlich auch ganz gut, dass Valorant mehr CS ist als Overwatch
Das wo Overwatch meiner Meinung nach schon seit längerem krankt ist, dass es zu
Zu wenig Shooter mehr ist. Die ganzen Melehelden. Es hat angefangen mit Brigitte
Ein Button Stun
Und solche Dinger. Was soll das überhaupt? So ein Schwachsinn
Sag mal, sind das immer noch irgendwelche Kinder, die das Spiel spielen? Warum spielen Kinder Black Ops 2 heute?
Black Ops 2 ist wie alt sechs Jahre. Die Kinder, die Black Ops 2 gespielt haben, sind heute 20
This is a brand-new lobby getting started here. I don't really like this map to be completely honest
Weil's billig ist ja, das kann sein
Das sind die Leute, die noch zum GameStop gehen und sich im GameStop für überteuern, die dann sich im GameStop für ihre acht Spiele
Fünf Euro geben lassen und dann von den fünf Euro ein altes Game mitnehmen
Jesus, dude, not cheating, but camping their heart out. Ja, paar Schimmler gab es da natürlich auch
Sieht aus wie eine mp7. Ist das eine mp7?
Ja, das ist eine mp7. Steht da unten rechts auch. Okay, I think we completely flipped spawns. Hold that
Sorry, buddy. Ich vergesse ja immer, dass Black Ops 2 so nur so ein bisschen future war, noch nicht komplett
All the way into their spawn right here. Come on. Well, actually, it's not really their spawn anymore
Jesus, teammate, you just scared me. Let me call this UAV in. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV
Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV
Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV
Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV in. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV in. Okay, I'm gonna call this UAV in. Now they're completely at the other side of the map
It's just not gonna come under here
Das Schneebert
Die Yamaha motor 24
Actually, I'm on a decent streak right now. I guess you can say black ops 2 is pretty much saved
I mean
Son die also ich spiele aktuell relativ viel modern warfare davor habe ich letzte zeit eigentlich hauptsächlich pass of exile gekreidet
Aber ich habe die letzten jahre wenig gespielt und ich merke das jetzt hardcore
So langsam aber sicher fange ich wieder an was zu treffen und sowas aber es ist echter wahnsinn wenn man ein paar jahre nicht gespielt hat
Wie schwer man sich tut an vielen stellen
modern
Die einzige Art wie die Leute dieses Spiel zu modieren ist durch RGH und ich denke durch eine Infektion durch eine RGH vielleicht
Auch eine gute Sache bei diesem Spiel ist, dass die Spielaufgabe sehr schnell ist
Ok, du bist tot
Ich muss diesen Jungen töten, richtig?
Orbital V ist gesessen, los!
Okay, wir müssen den Schwarm hier mit 11 und 1 bekommen
Okay, töten wir ihn gut
Nice, Blackbird am Start, beste!
Ich wünschte, dass ich einen modern warfare 2, modern warfare 3, modern warfare 3, modern warfare 3 hatte
zusammen, Blackbird, beste!
Da war eigentlich viel zu OP für das, was er gekostet hat. Ich weiß, was war Blackbird, 8er Killstreak?
Ich weiß es gar nicht mehr genau
Bester Killstreak im ganzen Game
Nicht nur im ganzen Game, in allen Games
In allen Call of Duty Games
Blackbird, beste!
Ich würde sagen, ich brauche zwei oder drei mehr Kills für einen Schwarm hier
ULV, Blackbird, Hunde, beste!
Orbital V sagt, es wird wahrscheinlich sehr, sehr bald weg
Oh, komm schon, Dude!
Bro, kein Witz, dieser Typ hat das Spiel komplett verlassen, als ich ihn schießen wollte
Okay, also aus der Sicht, sind alle hier spawnen
Danke, Team-Mate, für das UAB
Du bist tot
Und jetzt haben sie wieder komplett geflippt
Warum flippen sie immer so schnell?
Okay, ich glaube, noch einer mehr
Los, wir haben den Schwarm
War Black Ops 2 nicht?
Hayabiner, Hayabiner
War das Black Ops 2?
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, welches Game das war
Bambi, Bambi war Kod 4
Das Feuer ist voll
Das war Black Ops 2
Baustronen, Hoggers
Tango-Sucker
Wie findest du halt F4-Games?
Ich gucke mir fast jedes Video an, ich finde die Sachen nice
Weil ich jetzt schon leider nicht mehr reingeguckt habe
Der macht ja fast so regelmäßig Videos wie ich
Das ist live kommentiert, würde ich sagen
Der ist live am labern
Und für live redet er relativ viel
Blur 2, was ist Blur 2?
Das sagt mir gar nichts
Ah, schöner Scheibenwischer-Controller-Aim
Einige schnippen hier zurück
Los gehts, wir nennen den Lightning Strike
2, 3
Mal sehen, ob das einen oder zwei Töne holen kann
Okay, 10 und 0, los gehts
Wenn ich diesen Spiel 30 und 0 enden kann, wäre das ziemlich schön
Ich muss in den Orbital V gehen, los gehts
Wird das Kumpel hier rein?
Oh mein Gott, er hatte auch ein Schuss
Ich bin einfach bereit, um dort zu sterben
13 und 0 und ich werde von einer Grenade gefangen
Was ist mein Schuss?
31 ist noch ein guter 30 Kd
Die Jungs rennen hier hin
Ist er?
Ich hab ihn
Der Junge ist der andere Weg
Schuss, das war der Junge, der mich mit dem Semtex gefangen hat
Da werden sie weggesprayt
Die Gegner sind auch schon ganz genierlos wieder
Aber muss so sein
So sieht ein Game ohne Skill-Based Matchmaking aus
Skill-Based Matchmaking
Skill-Based Matchmaking ist dann die KLS-Variante
Ich kann das immer aussprechen
Skill-Based Matchmaking
So sieht mein Team aus in dem Spiel
Das ist wirklich so
Das eigene Team sackt immer
Was macht der Dude hinter dem Tresender?
Und dieser Junge ist sie
Was ist das?
Oh mein Gott, das Schuss
Ich bin so glücklich
Die Töne
Geh sie hin, Töne, geh sie hin
Bäm
Der wird jetzt geflammt
Der kriegt Flamemessages
Fucking Shotgun Noob
You got it bro
Aha, let's go, 30 in one
Easy
If you guys did, be sure to drop a like, subscribe if you guys are brand new
And if you're a Black Ops 2 fan, now's your time
The game is not hacked anymore
Finally put the smile on my face
Because most of the people that used the hitter mods
Would just be like terrible at the game
And they knew they had easy access
So they just spin pot, aim pot for no reason
So, was soll ich hier nochmal angucken?
Alpha 4 Games
Moment
Es gibt wirklich einen Channel
Ah, fast
Okay, was?
Der gecancelte Blur 2 Prototyp
Was ist Blur 2?
Rennt, gut
Er mag ja irgendwie Rennt Spiele
So früher hat er sich gerne
An Battlefield und Call of Duty abreagiert
In letzter Zeit kommen ziemlich viele Rennt Spiele
Blur 2, was hätte werden können?
Okay, zeigt mal hier
Das noch
Ach Moment, wir wollten ja noch was anderes gucken
Genau, Straßen überqueren
In Modern Warfare wollen wir noch angucken
Vom Stylers
Doch, den kenn ich
Das Video kenn ich auch
Das hab ich schonmal geguckt
Nichts da, nichts da, nichts da
Guckt mal, wo er sitzt
Guckt euch die Scheiße an
Guckt euch, das ist doch lächerlich
So für den Arsch, Alter
Das ist so die Sekunde
Das haben die so verschissen
Und ein Großteil der Probleme
Sind wirklich die Maps
Das ist ein Großteil
Dass sowas überhaupt möglich ist hier
Dass das da möglich
Das liegt schlicht ergreifend nur am
Layout der Map
Da wäre ich geraged quitted
Ich rage quitted nicht mehr in Modern Warfare
Weil ich will XP haben
Zum Waffen anlocken
Ich spiele in Modern Warfare Multiplayer
Absolut nicht mehr auf KD
Kannste auch nicht, KD ist
Tot in dem Spiel
Ich spiele das jetzt aktuell
Nur noch um Waffen zu anlocken
Und um sinnlos rein zu rushen mit der MP7
Und möglichst viele Kills zu machen
Und alle Gameplays, die ihr auf YouTube
So seht
Wo die Leute tatsächlich
Konsistent
Die die ganzen High-Kill
Gameplays machen, das sind entweder
Alle Lichtjahre mal
Einen Gameplay, okay
Mit viel Glück, aber das ist reverse
Geboostert ohne Ende
Die ganzen High-Kills
Das ist alles reverse
Geboostert ohne Ende
Dass du die richtigen
Kacknoobs als Gegner kriegst
Dann kriegt das fast jeder hin
Aber das ist wirklich
Das ist absolut true hier
Hast du einen Google-Account?
Ja, warum fragst du?
Ich hab sogar ein paar
Das ist so, das ist komplett
Das ist einfach nur true 0W
An der Stelle
True 03D
Naja, wenn ich YouTube Zeug mache, ich brauche einen Google-Account
Das ist, das ist, genau so ist es
Genau so ist es
Vor allem, was richtig, richtig gut ist
Das am Anfang hier auf der Map
Am Anfang
Du stehst hier eine halbe Stunde
Und schleichst und machst
Du hörst nichts, schießt
Du hörst nichts, es passiert nichts auf der Map
Nichts
Und dann sowas
Auch wenn du denkst, es kann nicht schlimmer
Komm, rennt er noch in die Claymore rein
Nein
Bäm
Oh Mann
Okay, gucken wir uns mal eine Runde Alpha 4 Games an
Um ehrlich zu sein
Nein
Das ist alte 4 Games
Ich weiß
Ich
Ich weiß, dass es nicht
Alpha 4 Games heißt
Laut genug
Also nicht zu laut machen
Nein, reicht, reicht
Bisschen laut
Das sieht aus wie
Garden Warfare Racer
Plans für die Zesomys Garden Warfare Racer
Alter
Ich ging viel mehr für zu reif hielten, weil mir ja bloß hinterbei erwischt werden wollte, wie man mit etwas Spaß hat
Okay, das ist jetzt etwas arg plump ausgedrückt
denn tatsächlich mochte ich diesen ansatz und vor allem dieses sehr
ehrliche marketing vom blur damals sehr ich kenne das nicht aber ich bin auch
kein rennspiele spiele spieler sammelt items und diese setzt diese taktisch
ein oder spammt einfach will drauf los für manchen hat ein bisschen was wie mario kart
oder besonders mit diesem effekt voll weg dass sie hier auf die augen gezwungen wird aber definitiv
eine der direktesten x trifft auf y umsetzungen die man sich von so einem konzept wünschen
könnte so richtig konnte blur bei mir allerdings nie wirklich klick machen nicht dass es schlecht
war aber es konnte für mich weder den reis eines fun racers noch den eines guten arcade racers
einfangen dafür war es mir einfach etwas zu träge etwas zu monoton etwas zu chaotisch die
strecken war nicht wirklich großartig und der pc port lief auch nie wirklich gut wobei mir
zumindest versichert wurde dass der split screen auf der konsole ziemlich gut war und wie viele
andere vielspieler rennspiele hatte so mit den noch auf der x-file spieler spieler ist ja
überhaupt nicht mehr angesagt aktuell das was blur in meinen außen außerbei nintendo nintendo
kriegt dafür online sachen nicht hin gebraucht hätte wäre ein nachfolger gewesen ein nachfolger
mit ein paar mehr frischen ideen und mehr entwicklungszeit und ein bisschen mehr geld
und wie viele von euch sicher schon wissen war genau so ein nachfolger tatsächlich mal in der
entwicklung doch da blöder und das entwickler studio geschlossen wurde wurde dieser letzten
endes gecancelt viel über die entwicklung war nicht bekannt bis dann jahre später ein gameplay
video einer frühen alpha version auftauchte mit deutlich imposanterer kulisse mit zerstörung
mit springen bis man plötzlich an der fensterwand eines riesigen gebäudes fährt das ist so cool
aus dass ich das hat was was ich spiele das hat wirklich was vor allem ist es genau diese extra
portion die dem original gefehlt hatte plötzlich war es richtig richtig schade dass das spiel
gecancelt wurde könnt ihr euch vorstellen was bizarre creations noch so alles vorhat
und vor allem wie denn erst das finale produkt ausgesehen hätte naja wie soll ich sagen letzteres
kann ich euch leider nicht bieten aber ich spiele es gerade ja jetzt im augenblick dieser uns
exklusiv vorliegende aber gar nicht mal so exklusive death build stammt vom november 2010
vier monate beschlossen wurde aber nur wenige tage bevor activision erstmals darüber redete
diesen schritt in erwägung zu ziehen offensichtlich handelt es ihr also noch um eine sehr frühe eine
wirklich sehr frühe version des spiels keineswegs vergleichbar mit einem fertigen überhaupt einem
vorzeigbaren produkt aber es gibt schon eine sehr gute ahnung darüber ab wie es mal hätte
werden können wäre das schicksal nur etwas gnädiger gewesen und das was wir nun hier
vor uns haben dieses kleine stückchen was hätte werden können schauen wir uns nun gemeinsam an
beim kurs aus dem gameplay league handelt es sich um eine der dubai strecken da diese noch am
weitesten fertiggestellt wurden hier sind die sprünge 2010 ist das schon so alt gewesen das
original alright und hier jemand da offenbar ein paar probleme mit seiner maschine hat wobei
fertiggestellt wohl noch etwas zu hoch gegriffen sein mag der prototyp den ich hier habe besteht
fast ausschließlich aus placeholder und entwickler grafiken ganz selten traut sich mal eine echte
textur oder ein fertiges model auf die straße wobei alles andere vorerst aus teil eins entliehen
wurde es gibt keine anderen fahrer es gibt keine spielmodi und selbst runden werden die eiken
sehen auch aus wie aus teil eins tatsächlich war der bild aus dem video schon um einiges
weiterentwickelt worden aber wir müssen uns nur mal mit dem zufrieden geben was wir haben dennoch
schaffte man es schon eine gewisse stimmung zu erzeugen deutlich zu machen wo das rennen statt
findet und wie die kulissen am ende aussehen könnten ha abseits davon ist es aber spielbar
manche strecken natürlich besser ja gut das ja normal wenn es wenn das zeug noch so unfertig ist
da kann das durchaus mal sein dass man dadurch im boden mit abfahren kann man sie und ich muss
schon sagen das stimmt alles placeholder aber hauptsache auch die mutung seit jahren dass ein
racer mit diesem war mit diesem riesen looping und mit dieser straßenführung spaß machen könnte hat
sich absolut bewahrheitet vielleicht hätte ich die dubai strecken aber nicht unbedingt als erstes
aufnehmen sollen weil sie sind nicht nur am weitesten sie sind auch die schwierigsten über
diese baustelle das gebäude hochfahren um von oka ist nicht dort wieder durchs nächste und von
dort wieder durchs nächste hochhaus zu springen ist fantastisch aber vermutlich genauso schwierig
wie es auch in echt sein würde erst recht auf der nächsten baustelle ist der sweet spot sehr hart
abzuschätzen großartig wenn du schaffst aber wirklich sehr hart dazu muss man sagen dass
es sich wohl um eins zu eins dasselbe fahrverhalten handelt wie noch im vorgänger
ohne spürbar an den neuen umstände angepasst worden zu sein das macht die sowieso schon sehr
träge steuerung für viele situationen recht ungeeignet und ist offensichtlich etwas was
im laufe der zeit noch hätte geändert werden sollen dafür bin ich aber um so erstaunter wie
die engine überhaupt damit blöde hatte seine sprünge aber nie irgendetwas wirklich außergewöhnlich
spektikuläres und dennoch kommt die karre damit klar und sogar die kamera kann damit umgehen
ja selbst an der decke fahren ist absolut kein problem noch sehr steif und störrisch ja klar
aber es funktioniert und es macht spaß es ist beeindruckend es ist aufregend und es gibt mir
selbst nach dem zehnten mal noch einen gewissen spiel die hongkong strecken sind da im vergleich
leider um einiges unspektakuläre unfertiger gameplay her als auch visuell wobei ich ganz
ehrlich denke dass ein indy racer mit einem ähnlichen stil sogar ganz angenehm aussehen
könnte nur halt ohne all diese hilfslinien natürlich blöde zwei sollte neben seinen
rundkursen auch a nach b strecken bekommen um down hill kurse zu realisieren und ich mag die
hier haben wir diesen tunnel mit den säulen den bitte absolut jedes rennspiel haben darf hier
einen sprung über die schlucht ich weiß nicht ob es nur mir so geht aber dieser berghang mit
den leuchtenden farben erinnert mich direkt an diese eine mario kart ds strecke würdest du
beide strecken vom layout aber nebeneinander stellen so würde die von blöd 2 definitiv
gewinnen die anderen hongkong level sind dafür aber wieder etwas bodenständig ich
frag mich warum ist das bild jetzt erst aufgetaucht wenn es von 2010 ist sie ja tisch aussehende
elemente in engstraßen welchen sich die connector verwendest du gar keinen ich habe zum größten
teile alles auf seawave und der rest des wlan pinkenstände ohne kollision erst dachte ich die
sollten vielleicht so etwas wie tribünen darstellen oder so aber ich denke es soll sich um solche
typischen marktstände handeln und wieso haben sie keine kollision na weil alles was pink ist
später zerstörbar sein sollte und so ein brettern durch den markt kann man sich vorstellen klingt
ziemlich plausibel ja man arbeitete tatsächlich an einem richtigen verkehr die man nicht nur
30 meter durch die luft schleudern kann sondern der tatsächlich auch auf den spieler reagiert
und anhält die l.a city bietet noch mehr verkehr noch mehr ausufernde steilkurven noch mehr
ausufern der rare steilkurven und das war schon die gesamte runde der baby park für leute mit
angst vor kurven sozusagen außerdem industrielle angehauchte kurse die dich im bester mit nightclub
manier durch den l.a river führen ich mag irgendwie ich hätte nicht erkannt dass das der l.a river
ist man so ganz ungefähr erkennt kann was alles darstellen soll und die farben sehr gut deutlich
machen was straße was dreck und was fützen sein soll es ist fast ein wenig erstaunlich dass es
auch ohne weitere information überhaupt möglich ist die meisten straßen gut zu navigieren und
auch wenn es absolut nichts mit irgendwas gerade zu tun hat blur hat die coolsten u-turns die
ich jemals in einem rennspiel gesehen habe ja das wollte ich mal hinzufügen
ok dann gibt es strecken die noch unfertig und barebones sind visuell von der kollision aber
auch vom layout manche strecken spawnen einen sogar direkt unter der map was jetzt nicht so
unbedingt abweich von den rennspielen die ich hier sonst vorstelle aber mit diesem stichwort
hinter uns können wir auch gleich mal zu den mayami strecken und zu diesem konstrukt hier
springen eine schraube mit sprung mittendrin und es klappt jedes mal ich möchte noch mal anmerken
dass dieser prototyp aus einer zeit stammt kennst du das zu lange ja das kenne ich das
war mario kart acht mit seinem antigravitations feature überhaupt angekündigt wurde und selbst
das spiel hat nicht einen sprung der so cool ist wie dieser hier es ist echt das perfekte
mayami flair coole karren sonniges wetter golfkurse der tornado da würde ich vor freude auch erstmal
tposen wollen die nordafrika rennstrecken sind noch ziemlich ziemlich verwirrend im design tauchen
aber wieder mehr dieses fantastische theming ab den berg rauf über den damm den berg runter
durch den fluss wieder zurück und solange man die scheinwerfer anmacht und nicht vom fad abkommt
ist es sogar machbar dass sie den prototyp von der 360 entwickler xbox haben die über die
über ebay wahrscheinlich verkauft wurde raushängen aus dem auto und unsere füße
ja man muss ja nicht mehr so kleinlich sein noch mehr hafen was auch immer strecken irgendwie
ist das ganze hier ein leichtes stück monothematisch kann das sein neben diesen
lebenswerten straßenlaternen und zwei sehr widerlichen kurven gibt es noch dieses umgekippte
containerschiff zu sehen man kann drüber fahren man kann durch fahren durch von das etwas schwieriger
drüber fahren ist ganz cool ja jetzt habt ihr es gesehen weiß jetzt müssen wir bescheid
erst dachte ich dass dubai und dann dass mayami die besten strecken layouts hatte aber nun muss
ich mich erneut korrigieren schi resort oh boy schi resort ich weiß dass diese ständigen
mario kart vergleiche sehr nervig sind ist jetzt nicht so das hat aber schon ein bisschen was
davon aber das meine ich nicht mal ansatzweise als kritik kennt ihr die wario abfahrt aus mk8
ja ja liebt ihr sie genauso sehr wie ich falls ja spätestens jetzt ist es eine schande das
blur 2 gecancelt wurde die erste pistenstrecke ist noch ziemlich öde und zieht sich die nächste
aber ist fantastisch dank der abfahrt bist du super super schnell unterwegs der untergrund
bringt dich mehr entschleudern als sonst keiner hat ihr gestreut so viel steht mal fest aber die
kurven sind weit genug um das auszugleichen meistens zumindest leise leid es geht viel
hin und her das driften fühlt sich richtig gut an später kommt noch ein partikelleffekt runter
der platz halte für eine lawine sein könnte oder irgendwie sowas ist super es ist so eine
großartige strecke und dann gibt es noch die ice cave ich sehe die cave ich sehe das eis ich sehe
keinen pinguin der im tunnel rum steht aber ich sehe war rights über abgründe hier stimmt das
auto passt nicht wirklich das haben sie halt am ersten teil kopiert die besten der spiel zu bieten
hat wobei eigentlich schnee und rennspiele und glatteis und autos normalerweise nichts aber hier
hier ist es fantastisch die detroit level wurden mit folgender idee gebaut detroit hat lava oder
magma oder flüssiges metall oder irgendetwas und eine autofabrik mach was daraus teilweise
noch sehr rudimentäre konzepte und so so ohne wende und alles es hat diesen part hier der ist
nett und es gibt diese nette schraube hier die klappt nicht immer aber wenn es klappt dann
klappt es und das waren auch schon alle strecken oder zumindest die die auch fahrbar sind und nicht
sofort kraschen jeder der erwähnt könnte bettel viel hat eine eigene unter strecken die man mehr
mal weniger ineinander übergehen und offenbar war noch um einiges mehr geplant bevor der laden
dicht gemacht wurde revolution erst mal die highlights blur zwei war zu diesem stand noch
kaum spiel mit einem fahrverhalten das nur die meiste zeit stabil genug ist ein paar weniger
eindrucksvolle layout zu bieten hat und nur mit groben konzepten wie es am ende aussehen sollte
dennoch war mal aus der experimentierphase wohl bereits raus und schon mittendrin den
tatsächlichen content zu planen und zu produzieren wäre aus blöd zwei ein gutes spiel geworden
hätte es als nachfolger funktioniert oder sich einfach zu weit von der eigenen identität
verabschiedet oder könnte es überhaupt erfolgreich sein wenn schon der vorgänger keine verkaufssahlen
generieren konnte die antwort auf all diese fragen ist am ende des tages aber war es nicht
egal und eine diskussion darüber ist jetzt auch nicht der zweck von diesem video hier es ist
schade was aus bizarre creations wurde von der erfolgreichen project goffin racing serie und
meine güte ich liebe mein geometry wars und 007 blattstone was beides keineswegs schlechte
spiele sind nur zwei flops damit publisher activision endgültig den stecker zog das war
das das war das james bond game in der call of duty engine es hat einfach alles was ich brauche
es ist over the top aber ohne gleich albern zu sein also sage jetzt einfach mal es hat richtig
coole strecken es hat t post manner und du kannst durch die map fallen ein richtiges alt f4 game
also das will man bitte noch von einem rennspiel aber die leute immer so mit ihrem realismus
tunig türen und auch wenn das zum großteil sicher mit der schieren novelty zusammenhängt
etwas zu spielen was mir erschienen ist das schier im novelty um all der verschiedenen
kurse für knapp zwei stunden echt meinen spaß leider leider muss ich euch nun aber damit
enttäuschen dass ich euch allein schon aus rechtlichen gründen keinen download verlinken
werde aber ich kann euch zumindest das nächste bieten nämlich einen langen unkommentierten
playthrough aller verfügbaren strecken für all die leute die sich für diese stückchen
verlorene video spielgeschichte dieses kleine was hätte werden können interessieren links
sind jetzt irgendwie da und in der beschreibung und ich mache gerade so eine zeitbewegung
auch wenn ich mich überhaupt null also ich interessiere mich ja null nicht gar nicht für
rennspiel interessiere wo ich sagen da schafft es immer videos zu machen die man sich gerne
anguckt oder hätte deutlich mehr abos verdient ich weiß gar nicht warum da warum das so wenig
abos hat da ich mir überhaupt nicht ein aber es ist wahrscheinlich nicht das was in youtube
deutschland 2020 reinpasst jetzt die hidra view näher denn ich lüge doch als ich habe
hunger wie sau nachher muss ich also ich werde es demnächst was essen gehen und dann muss
man weiter vergrinden vielleicht mache ich dann wirklich mal den stream an dass ihr mich
sehen könnt wie ich abkacke wobei ich gar nicht mehr so extrem abkacke im vergleich
noch von vor ein paar tagen wie nordkorea geld verdient das muss man jetzt mal angucken
es interessiert mich wie nordkorea geld verdient seit jahrzehnten gibt es umfangreiche was
hältst du von edge os was ist das ach das ding ich dachte jetzt ich dachte jetzt das
gegenstück zu chrome os plus von microsoft ich habe mich damit nie großartig beschäftigt
ich habe einen edge switch und alles super hatte damit nie irgendwelche probleme ich
habe aber auch nicht viel eingestellt so seit jahrzehnten gibt es umfangreiche sanktionen
gegen nordkorea waffen rohstoffe maschinen fahrzeuge luxusgüter chemikalien textilien
fast kein land der welt handelt mit dem totalitären regime aber die chinesen oder die chinesen
sind doch noch am start ich habe letztens ein video gesehen von irgendwelchen leuten
die geflüchtet sind aus nordkorea und haben gesagt die flüchten zum größten teil über
den fluss nach china und dann teilweise auch dann nach südkorea über china und die bestechen
die wachen quasi an der grenze und warten bis winter der fluss zugefroren ist und hauen
dann über den fluss ab aber die müssen alle abhauen wenn sie abhauen weil ansonsten erschießen
sie die komplette familie erschießen sie die ganze familie eltern kinder großeltern
alles nur weil einer geflüchtet ist das ist richtig monka es in nordkorea handelt kauft
das land viel mehr ein als es verkauft so verschuldet sich das land international immer weiter die
wirtschaft stagniert seit jahren millionen von menschen leben in bitterer armen was ist
es für einheiten was sind das für einheiten in billionen südkoreanischer wonn das ist ja
für mich jetzt absolut nicht vergleichbar jetzt seit jahren millionen von menschen leben in
bitterer armut all das spricht nicht gerade dafür dass nordkorea so reich ist wie es sich
gerne gibt macht aber kim jong-un lässt prächtige denkmeller bauen unterhält ein gigantisches
militär und finanziert ein aufwendiges macht sich ja auch gut dafür dürften die einnahmen
des landes eigentlich auf gar keinen fall reichen woher kommt also das ganze geld weil
die leute verhungern verheerende cyberangriffe geldfälschung und moderne sklaverei auf der
jagd macht nordkorea vor wirklich nichts halt nordkoreas eigene währung der one ist fast
überall im ausland so gut wie nichts wert das muss man nachgucken 0,1 cent 0,1 cent ist ein
nordkoreanischer wonn excellent währung ja da kann man bestimmt gut urlaub machen
rein vom geld her zu können braucht man dollar yuan oder euros aber wie kann man
international anonym und vor allem schnell viel geld verdienen lange vermutete man das
ist in pyeongyang tatsächlich eine eigene behörde nur für diesen zweck gibt das mysteriöse
büro 39 verschiedene leaks und etliche nordkoreanische flüchtlinge bestätigen heute unabhängig
voneinander die existenz des büros dazu gibt es übrigens auch eine spannende doku in der
ztf mediathek die nordkoreanische regierung verheimlicht aber nicht nur warum wackeln
die bilder warum wackeln die bilder so das büro 39 dieses video ist teil einer zusammenarbeitung
vom kanal mr wissen to go auf seinem kanal findet ihr ein weiteres sehr interessantes
video zu den düsteren geheimnissen nordkoreas einen link findet ihr in der beschreibung
das büro 39 das habe ich nicht gemacht ich soll also ausländisches geld für das regime
beschaffen egal wie ende der 80er gelangten die machenschaften des büro 39 zum ersten
mal an die öffentlichkeit diese 100 dollar note sieht wahnsinnig echt aus ist sie nicht
von diesen scheinen waren unzählige im umlauf kamerad genau gefälscht dass man sie super
notes taufte sie stammen ehemaligen nordkoreanischen diplomaten zufolge aus nordkorea so ist es
wahrscheinlich abgelaufen die regierung hat damals einige gelddruckmaschinen gekauft
dasselbe modell mit dem auch echte dollarnoten gedruckt werden die gedruckten supernotes
wurden dann diplomaten mitgegeben bis heute sind sie mit ihrem gesonderten status die
laufbuschen des regimes sie haben die supernotes im ausland dann zb in banken eingezahlt und
sich im anschluss echte dollar auszahlen lassen die wurden dann kofferweise zurück nach pyeongyang
geliefert vermutlich sind immer noch mehrere millionen dieser supernotes im umlauf ob die
gelddruckmaschinen heute noch scheine drucken ist unklar 2005 und 2006 sind bei internationalen
versicherern zahlreiche forderungen eingegangen unter anderem auch bei der allianz ein helikopter
sein pyeongyang abgestürzt zwei züge sein verunglückt und eine faire sei gesunken alles
war im ausland versichert das versicherungsmonopol korea national insurance corporation hat allein
mit helikopter abstürzen mindestens 58 wer versichert denn nordkoreanische helikopter
millionen dollar von verschiedenen globalen versicherern erhalten vieles spricht allerdings
dafür dass die unfälle nur inszeniert waren wenn in deinem t-shirt made in china steht besteht
die chance dass es eigentlich in nordkorea produziert wurde chinesische textilunternehmen
lagern ihre produktion immer häufiger an günstige fabriken in nordkorea aus dort arbeiten die
angestellten häufig unter unmenschlichen bedingungen moment die chinesen über die
wir uns beschweren dass dort unmenschliche arbeitsbedingungen sind lagern diese sache
nach nordkorea nach nordkorea aus wo noch unmenschliche arbeitsbedingungen sind habe
ich das jetzt richtig verstanden ja in unserem shirt steht hinterher nur made in china auch
nordkoreas export gehen weiter vor allem öl und kohle sollen immer noch in viele nachbarländer
exportiert werden laut einem bericht der vereinten nationen liefert nordkorea außerdem waffen
meist über internationale gewässer insbesondere nach afrika und in den nahen osten um unentdeckt
zu bleiben wird die identität des jeweiligen schiffes gefälscht die funksysteme werden
manipuliert so wurde syrien zwischen 2012 und 2017 mit mindestens 40 schiffsladungen
beliefert mit hoher wahrscheinlichkeit waren sie für assads chemiewaffen programm bestimmt
im syrischen bürgerkrieg sind durch diese chemiewaffen zahlreiche unschuldige menschen
ums leben gekommen gut die denken sich halt auch irgendwoher müssen wir die kohle bekommen
sie können ja im endeffekt auch nichts legales machen es macht ja mit ihnen keiner was was
sollen sie denn auch legales machen derzeit 2,6 millionen nordkoreaner in moderner sklaverei
das land verleiht einen teil seiner bevölkerung höchstwahrscheinlich als zwangsarbeiter insbesondere
nach china russland und südostasien einige sollen bis vor kurzem auch auf europäischen
baustellen zum einsatz gekommen sein zurückgebliebenen familien dienen als geiseln sie sind für
viele zwangsarbeiter der einzige grund nicht in die freiheit zu fliehen ja ein ermittler
der vereinten nationen schätzt dass die nordkoreanische regierung auch heute noch alleine durch zwangsarbeit
ein nahmen in milliardenhöhe verzeichnet so gut wie kein nordkoreaner hat zugang zum
internet trotzdem verfügt das land über eine cyberarmee rund 1000 cyberarmee sollen für
nordkorea im einsatz sein dafür soll sogar wie bilden sie die überhaupt aus weiteres
büro gegründet worden sein büro 121 2016 wurde die zentralbank von bangladesh gehackt
mehrere millionen dollar da haben sich ja die profis untereinander die nordkoreanischen
superhacker hack sonn bangladesh wurden gestohlen das fbi ist davon überzeugt von profis für
profis seine finger im spiel hatte der warne cry hack top das allerdings bei weitem 2017
wurden über 200.000 windows computer was war der cry war nordkoreanisch echt dann
mit dem wurm infiziert der wurm hat auf diesen computern alle daten verschlüsselt danach
erschien diese löse geldforderung man soll man das nordkoreaner um seine daten wiederzukriegen
kann ich mich gar nicht dran erinnern dass nordkoreaner waren
originated from north korea kann ich mich überhaupt nicht mehr dran erinnern dass das nordkoreaner
waren würden sie für immer verschlüsselt bleiben hunderte millionen dollar schaden
wurden so angerichtet die amerikanische britische und australische regierungen sind
sich sicher dass nordkorea hinter dem angriff steckt und jetzt also machen schafften nordkoreas
werden seit den 2000ern nicht mehr ausschließlich von der regierung gesteuert in den 90ern gab es
eine schwere hungersnot bei der hunderttausende nordkoreaner gestorben sind damals hat das regime
versagt sein volk zu schützen als konsequent ist das leute war ist das der gleiche ist das
der gleiche oder sind das unterschiedliche die sehen sich sonn und vater ok weil die
sehen original original gleich aus die haben die haben quasi die statue einfach zweimal
gemacht zu schützen als konsequenz haben sich zahlreiche schwarzmärkte gebildet diese
kann die regierung nur teilweise kontrollieren die betreiber dieser schwarzmärkte arbeiten
oft eng mit der korrupten regierung zusammen sie drückt nämlich immer ein auge zu zumindest
solange ein teil des geldes auch in staatskassen fließt auf den schwarzmärkten werden nicht
nur lebensmittel kleidung und alltagsgegenstände gehandelt sondern auch drogen und ausländische
währungen ein großer teil dieses inoffiziellen handels findet mit china statt die grenze im
norden ist nämlich sehr lang und viel weniger bewacht als die zu südkorea das ist da wo die
leute immer flüchten chinesische behörden beschlagnahmten 2011 drogen aus nordkorea im
wert von 60 millionen dollar immer wieder werden in china hunderte kilo betäubungsmittel gefunden
die im nachbarland produziert wurden nordkorea zählt zu den isoliertesten ländern der welt
kim jong-un tut fast alles um sein land so gut es geht abzuschotten in mr. wissen to ghost video
erfahrt ihr was das regime seinen eigenen bürgern und dem rest der welt verheimlicht es liefert
einen wahnsinnig spannenden einblick in die düsteren seiten nordkoreas das land ist ganz
offensichtlich auf seine außenwelt angewiesen nordkoreas jetzt wissen wir bescheid es hat
gerade irgendjemand wer war das hier im chat der cliff twitch 2 sagt hey max ich habe in vier
wochen meine schriftliche abschlussprüfung mal hier angucken wo ist mein pepega bord
also ich habe ich habe in vier wochen meine schriftliche abschlussprüfung zum fachinformatik
kor korrekte schreibweise anwendungsentwicklung hast du irgendwelche tips wie hast du dich für
die abschlussprüfung vorbereitet es gibt eigentlich nur eine möglichkeit sich für die
abschlussprüfung vorzubereiten und das ist sich alte abschlussprüfung anzugucken fertig
das war es die sind auch nicht schwer die iak prüfung generell ist ist ist das was die die
ausbildung an sich ist ist ist ist eigentlich ziemlich lächerlich sowohl von der berufsschule
als auch von der iak her und so das ist wirklich nicht schwer das einzige was man lernen muss ist
zu verstehen was die iak wissen will das ist das schwierigste die antworten auf die fragen
kennst du alle ein punkt also ein teil kannst ja komplett streichen und das schwierige ist
die fragestellung der iak zu checken und deswegen musste einfach alte zwischenprüfung machen
fertig das war es machst du fünf sechs stück da weißt du bescheid lebt king kim jong un jetzt
noch oder ist er tot also ich glaube da bin ich der falsche das zu beantworten ich habe
keinerlei insider information aus nordkorea keine ahnung
so was hacker reagiert auf doku das ju die 45 minuten ist zu lang das gucken wir uns
das gucken wir uns demnächst noch mal an das gucken wir uns demnächst auch nicht jetzt das
ist jetzt zu lang das video haben wir ja geguckt diese dieses dieses was war das original video
mit den zwei mcdonalds hackern war das mit den zwei mcdonalds hackern das hier cyber
kriminalität für sehr etwas hackerin das haben wir geguckt da habe ich ja mein senf schon
dazu gegeben als krasse hacker man und mal gucken was der dazu sagt das gucken wir uns aber nicht
heute alles zu lang how to not shoot a machine gun das kokona video aller hell yeah wenn ich
das sehen das ist ein typisches kokona video so ja das frage ich mich auch
nein das gucke ich mir nicht an das pz lustig das sieht schon eklig aus auf auf dem thumbnail
dieses mainboard ist definitiv defekt ich glaube nicht ja und weiter das zeug so hart
wer mal da passt oder gekratzt excellent how badly battlefield 5 really failed shocking
numbers revealed diese titel immer shocking erst erst ganz normaler titel oder schocking numbers
revealed if you don't like it don't bite das war so fail von dem da ist mensch
oh i sound mega nasally in this video because i've got terrible hay fever which is awful so go easy
on me it sucks i hope you enjoy what the fuck oh and shameless plug subscribe why not all right
let's do this bye ladies and gents welcome to the video i'm get good the battlefield 5 the
unreal engine 5 demo haben wir uns schon angeguckt ja und today i'm going over just how much of a
failure but so far ich will die schockierenden zahlen will ich jetzt sehen schockigen numbers
aber wo sind sie bashing on the game schockigen numbers in actual figures anyway that we simply
haven't been able to do zum thema shocking talking about how things went wrong or the future now i
played as much bf5 as i could mentally stand for the background footage today and i was doing all
of it with a broken controller that constantly looks up in the air so if i don't have an okay moment leute okay
okay das ist nicht der größte youtube channel ja aber er neuen controller sollte er sich leisten können
footage for the whole thing i'll throw up old stuff afterwards i'm sure you won't mind and i wanted
to let you know regardless now there is a bit of a long intro to come here fair warning as well as
very in-depth video overall it is necessary today if that doesn't sound like your sort of thing then so
be it i'll catch you in a different video thanks for trying so while it will take a while to get
through all of this ist ja was mich übelst triggert mittlerweile auf youtube das ist dass das das nimmt
jetzt immer weiter dass das schlägt jetzt immer weiter ein auch auf dort auch auch in deutschen videos
dass die erste minute weil weil mittlerweile die zuschauer schon auf youtube so eine kurze
aufmerksamkeit sparen haben und so ultra leicht durch jeden scheiß getriggert werden dass die leute
die erste minute mittlerweile damit verbringen einen disclaimer rein zu packen so nach dem motto wenn
euch diese art von video nicht gefällt ich habe auch noch jede menge anderen videos so nach dem
motto alter seid nicht angepisst auf mich guckt euch auch mal das ist das nimmt mittlerweile
wirklich schon schon ausmaße an das ist fast in total vielen videos sehe ich das
big brain chat grade am start
Alter
Exzellent Jet
Wo sei ich jetzt die Baro?
Ja Alter, komm zu Punkt, mach mal hinne!
Ja, auf!
Ja!
Das stimmt, das sagt wirklich!
Für Battlefield 5 gibt es diese Seiten
BF, BF 4 Stats, BF 3 Stats und so
gibt's nicht
und ich hab den Typ damals getroffen
auf dem Battlefield 1 Event in Berlin
der diese Seiten macht und hat auch gesagt
es wird immer schwieriger da dran zu kommen
und die wollen gar nicht mehr
das ist
was?
Die wollte es halt ein bisschen verschleiern
Was? Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, was?
Äh, estimated
wie auch immer die das
errechnet haben, da haben wir so einen Link
unten drunter, ganz gut, dass man sich das auch mal ankommen kann
also hier ist es raus
Wann kam das Game raus?
Wann war Release?
BF5 Release Date
2018, Ende 2018
ok, 40.000
das ist doch
wenig, 40.000 ist
mega schlecht, Alter
40.000, das ist
viel zu wenig, oder
nur für eine Plattform, oder was?
also wenn das wirklich alle
Plattformen beinhalten sollte
ach nur PC
ja ok
hat er gesagt nur PC?
ok, ok
aber trotzdem ganz schön wenig
trotzdem ganz schön wenig
kann man, ich muss euch mal kurz was fragen
kann man auf der Xbox und der Playstation
in Warzone Cosplay deaktivieren?
weil auf dem PC geht das glaube ich nicht
voll random, ich weiß die Frage jetzt
nur mal der PS4 ok
Alter komm mal, mach mal hin
wo sind die shocking Numbers?
ja das ist wenig
gibt es zu Warzone
PC, Spielerzahl
gibt es nicht extra Plattform
nee, gibt es nicht, einfach nur für PC
das läuft auf Battle.net ja
ja, aber wenn man den Leuten von Anfang an auch erzählt
kauft euch das Game nicht, muss man sich nicht wundern
wisst ihr was ich cool finde
der baut die Sätze immer so auf
als kommt jetzt gleich was
dann baut er den nächsten Satz so auf
dann kommt der nächste Satz, der wird so aufgehört
als kommt jetzt gleich was, aber es kommt nichts
ja
shocking Numbers
ich hab Hunger
ich hab grad was zu essen gebracht gekriegt
ich hab gerade geiles Timing
da bin ich jetzt noch kurz ein bisschen länger da und futter was
und gucken wir uns gleich noch ein Barbecue Pit Boy Video an
eine Katze hat's gebrochen, genau
jetzt bringe ich der Katze immer was, er kann immer ein bisschen erkenntlich zeigen
CSGO Player Numbers im Vergleich zu Battlefield Player Numbers
will er weinen oder was
Leute, das Video ist dumm
ich guck jetzt mal vor
was es für, ob der da irgendwie noch shocking Numbers drinne hat
nein
shocking Numbers
massive shocking Numbers
da war was
du hast es geskippt, ja egal
ist jetzt wurscht
wir springen jetzt gleich zu dem Beef Torpedo Sub Recipe
das muss ich mir jetzt angucken
und dabei esse ich mal kurz mal ein Reis hier
ah yes, exellent
bei den Brötchen
achten sie ja auch immer peinlich genau drauf, dass das die Brötchen mit dem absolut niedrigsten Gesundheitsfaktor und Gehalt sind überhaupt
die Machete, die ist ja halt doppelt so groß wie sonst
jetzt werden erst mal mit der Machete Brötchen geschnitten, Brötchen geschmiert und danach auch umgedreht
da wird alles mit der Machete gemacht
ich vermute mal, dass davon nützt auch keiner ein Beef Torpedo Sub
oh wird der Sushi, Sushi, Sushi gerollt
Sushi Hackfleisch Rolls
wird er auch gleich die Soße an mit der Machete, ja höchstwahrscheinlich
wie er immer nacht dazwischen
wird alles mit der Machete gemacht
das gibt wirklich Hackfleisch Sushi
das ist eigentlich ziemlich Big Brain
was ist das? ist das eine Tomate?
trocknete Tomate? ne, was ist das?
Köftespieß, ne das ist definitiv kein Köftespieß
erst mal schön mit der Machete alles verschmieren, exellent
Muts?
guck der hat so nen schönen Pizzaschieber
die haben echt 50 verschiedene Grills
hier ist mal für was unter Machete alles Gutes
Brötchen schmieren, Zeugs durchschneiden, Soßen umrühren
außerdem stimmt warum kommt da Gemüse rein, das ist schon fragwürdig
wie der Käse runterdropft
also ich würde das jetzt auch futtern
das würde ich mir jetzt auch geben
das wird der Italiener aber anders sehen
ich würde ja fast sagen, dass das Brötchen eigentlich so schon voll genug ist
und wenn du das jetzt noch rein steckst, das ist wahrscheinlich wieder so voll, dass du es kaum essen kannst
erst mal schön den Mund verbrennen
Leute ich kann nicht ordentlich streamen, sondern dabei essen
wenn ich ordentlich essen würde, halte es in annehmbarer Zeit, dass es nicht kalt wird
vielleicht sehen wir uns nachher mal mit einer Runde Modern Warfare
müssen wir mal schauen, vielleicht, vielleicht, aber da gibt es irgendwann den schausten kann, der es verdient hat, der es auch gebrauchen kann
okay Leute, wir machen jetzt Schluss
war der Käse in der Mitte, ja, ja, ja
und dann eingewickelt in Hackfleisch
ja, wir machen jetzt Schluss, wir sehen uns im nächsten Stream
es war schön, dass so viele Leute dabei waren, ein leiser Stream, machts gut, bis dann, see you